[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh you're trying to get here no no yes
[Music]
[Music]
please please please please
this would be stalemate if I don't do
this put the d5 pawn on e6 and you will
see that magic huh yes I've never
wow that was a mind that's like a glitch
was that oh it's a French term it means
in passing so it's almost the same as if
the bond would be lost one squared
okay don't play that quickly on the
start now oh my god
I wasn't expecting him to do that what
the hell no loot it the bombs coming
okay get in the car get in the car I
[Music]
can't get back up there I'm in lose
oh I had checkmate I got so scared
[Music]
once I got disconnected anyone seconds
you could win it's a chance he
everything sorry in my office
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello everybody and welcome to pogchamp
where we are going to be bringing
streamers together from a variety of all
different backgrounds to face off in
chess i'm joined today by the one and
only G mu Kaoru Nakamura who was really
a big force behind the vision for this
event Hikaru thanks so much for thinking
about this in being here yeah thanks for
having me certainly I think this has
been quite a while in the and it's
coming together I think for the past
couple of weeks
many people have been discussing it's
great to see the tournament coming
together and all these streamers
competing in it and I think certainly
there gonna be a lot of interesting
games are gonna be some very clickable
moments for sure so just looking forward
to it yeah they will be very clickable
moments hopefully both entertaining with
some interesting blenders and also some
some pretty impressive chess because I
know a lot of the streamers have been
grinding and working on their chess game
right yeah I think it's it's certainly
gonna be interest interesting to see who
is sort of internalized and learned the
most I think pretty much all the
streamers have gotten some form of
coaching through lessons and so it'll
just be interesting to see who is who's
learned the most and who is able to
utilize what they've learned the best
absolutely and today we're starting off
with group a so that's gonna be boy boy
who's Lee you Rob 221 and Nate Hill and
moving on to the format to explain that
a little bit to everyone players are
going to be split into four groups of
four so we're seeing the first group
today they are going to play a single
round-robin meaning they're each going
to play one of the other opponent one
time the time control is going to be ten
minutes with five second increment each
time they make a move they get an
additional five seconds we are
incentivizing people to play for a win
we want it to be exciting so wins are
worth 3 points draws are worth 1 point
and of course losses say the same zero
points no pity points here the top two
are going to advance into the
championship bracket the bottom to
advance to the consolation bracket so
regardless what happens today we will be
seeing more of these streamers and yeah
let's let's start to maybe profile them
a little bit today we have a Rob 221 he
is a variety streamer he has a really
funny community that likes to troll that
he is Tyler ones brother since they look
somewhat alike I guess we're here just
pushing the meme a little bit further we
also have Foose Lee another variety
streamer and he is going to be facing
her off in the first match of the
pogchamp tournament Hikari you want to
comment on the prizes for the tournament
yeah so they're gonna be two brackets
there will be a championship bracket and
a consolation bracket so the top two
players from each group go on to the
champions bracket bottom two go to the
consolation bracket in the championship
bracket the first prize will be 10,000
sandals
second prize will be 6,000 third or
doctorate story this how many finalists
will be 3,000 quarterfinals mm and then
the consolation 4000 to the winner 3,000
to the loser on the two semi finals get
two thousand the two quarterfinals get
1250 so everybody is guaranteed to get
at least $1,250 well it seems like a
pretty good prize just to play then and
yeah let's take a little bit look at the
schedule before we get started the games
will be starting soon so we do have the
complete schedule it's gonna be from
June 5th to June 14th and yeah we're
starting off today and it's going to be
basically every single day until the
14th
we'll have between two to three games so
hopefully you guys check back on
twitch.tv slash s so that you can you
know catch this event and on that note I
guess let's let's go back to your chest
calm I'm gonna make sure that I'm
following the players so that I don't
miss the action just give me one second
there and and while I do that do you
have any predictions for ear obverses
foosley um I've seen both of them play a
little bit of chess I guess what I would
say is that it seems to me that from a
little bit of watch a Rob is probably
overall a better player he seems to have
a better understanding um whereas
foosley feels like when she reaches
puzzles or situations where you can find
a forest solution she's she's been doing
quite well so I think a lot is gonna
depend on what happens and probably the
first 10 moves I'm gonna make a
prediction and just because this is
twitch and the spirit of twitch I am
gonna predict that the Arab is gonna
take another L and foosley is going to
win the game wow that's a bold
prediction you go and
I guess one of the things that we're
gonna see play a role into this is both
of the experience the players had before
so obviously if somebody had been
playing a little bit more chess but also
how much they've been grinding until the
upcoming event and I know you've been
helping with some coaching also we have
lift-off I'm about to follow their game
okay so what is it is d4 to start so so
one thing that's gonna be interesting
here is we're gonna see um like who's
been watching each other streams and
what they've been doing I think this I
did show closely this opening last night
so I'm very familiar with what she's
playing but we will see we will see how
Iran responds he's taking a lot of time
here which tells me this is a very bad
sign at the start because he should have
done some preparation on this um do you
think this is the first time he's
encountered d4 probably not but I'm
guessing okay so so I I'm a little bit
surprised by this opening so far that I
Rob is thinking because Foose is
definitely I was showing her this
opening yesterday so because of that I
think I my guess is that the damage at
least two moves into the game it's
definitely on foosley side she's gotten
exactly what she wants she wants to push
her pawn and free up the bishop on the
light squares actually since I literally
get a lesson I'm I feel like I'm
repeating myself from what I said last
night but again you guys other thing
that's gonna be important I think we're
gonna see a lot of this is that the time
situation the management the time is
gonna be very very important um so let's
let's see what happens so I think this
is a very critical moment already
we'll see if oke Rob plays c5 okay so
now loosely should remember this because
she does have a very good memory she's
gonna she's gonna build the hat here and
then put the bishop the hob public
behind her underneath the hat so so far
pretty pretty standard nothing - nothing
too special
okay and now she gets what she wants so
she should of course put the bishop in
the Hat I love the way you're explaining
these strategies the bishop in the Hat
that's the first time I've heard it for
the London system but that does make it
a little bit easier to remember remember
I'm surprised though because it does
seem like you're
is also playing theory how are your
expectations in the sense that players
focus on theory versus just playing
basic opening principles um so I think
the thing that's important to remember
is everybody has some basic set up there
that they're looking at and I think that
the critical thing to remember here is
is who is a better better memory like
this opening specifically firstly I
showed her this exact position from a
different move hoarder and and I think
she remembers that she played this movie
three very quickly whereas I would sort
of expect her to get confused more
easily if she had looked at this before
so um Iran plays c4 okay so this is a
very tricky move here this is actually
not a good move though she should
probably move her Knight out here but
we'll see we'll see what she does yeah
it seems like he's trying to bait her
into taking the pawn on c4 and going for
a move like Queen B - that's attacking
the road can putting pressure on c3 at
the same time if the knight moves that
can become a little bit of a tricky
situation whoa she saw it are you are
you a proud kochu karu I'm very happy
with what I've seen so far I think I
said this on stream last night when I
when I did coach her in the short-term
like even in the little bit between like
reviewing the news and then when she
played later she seemed to be the person
who was remembering who was remembering
her ideas better than anyone else so I
think it's it's is it's not that
surprising to me because I had already
reached conclusion last night but she's
she's already winning the game and she
takes the pawn with her white pawn on on
b3 just capture that pawn and she'll be
up a pond she'll be plus-one okay she
doesn't do it so I guess it's it's still
okay she's trying to follow the original
plan um that I looked at was her last
night but I think we're gonna see a lot
of blood back and forth I am actually
very happy to see those there have been
no mistakes like nobody has blundered
anything um no any - the pawn on c4 but
that's small enough I guess we could
pretend right I guess what I mean those
like what I've seen most on play just
random games most of them contain
bishops or nights or rooks very early
like within the first ten move so the
fact that we're all ready to I think
like move six removes seven is is it's
very good to see how competitive this
game is yeah that's very because you
know for a lot of people who are
starting off
chess relatively new you can have
fantastic memory like foosley and start
to remember the opening repertoire but
what you really need just time to train
is your pattern recognition so that you
don't fall for four tactics so I mean
how much do you think these games are
gonna be determined just by basic
tactics um I would say I mean I think I
think some some Ian's are gonna be big
mismatches where one person is just much
stronger but in a game like this I would
say most likely it will be determined by
who spots attacks I think both sides
will probably make mistakes so I don't
think you're gonna have any games where
one side makes a mistake that's fatal
yeah we keep it in the twitch twitch
terms I like that so it seems like who's
Lee now she has gotten control of the
center here but you Rob is making some
really intuitive moves by just trying to
develop he has forgotten about the pawn
on c4 but as you said that probably
shouldn't make the decisiveness
of the game right but already it's very
critical um I think Iran is in quite a
bit of trouble here because the part of
the problem again and this is one of the
reasons I showed who's - this opening
yesterday is that it's very easy to come
up with a plan like White has developed
the Knights white only needs to develop
the one Bishop they get the king out of
the center and position is very very
critical for Iran like very critical
already he's okay so he takes a knight
which is probably the best move FUS lee
should take with the pawn here so you
like foolishly taking off with the pawn
because you want her to keep her Bishop
there and he cards that was like she's
listening to you she's gonna good
student yeah I mean I it's it's a very
tricky position both players are gonna
probably make blunders for sure but the
fact that they've reached they've
reached a position out of the opening
phase where you really aren't seeing any
major mistakes yet it's it's gonna be
it's gonna be a fun game and they're
both are moving relatively quick now
unfortunately Bishop d3 is a bad move
but Arad misses the pawn yeah and I'm
drawing arrows here to show people yeah
so II Rob could have taken the the pawn
on e5 it was attacked twice by the two
knights and now we'll see if Foose Lee
sees how she could defend it she can
either capture first on d5 and then
bring her knight to f3 or she could just
bring her knight to f3 right away or
what do you think about queen h5 should
she go for I think she well I was gonna
say based on what I showed her yesterday
with a similar setup Queen h5 is the
moves that I would expect here because I
did show her a very similar position so
she does remember it's kind of the
concepts I do think she will play queen
h5 but but we'll see we'll see I kind of
hope it's gonna happen just because it
would be fun to see how you rob is gonna
defend I mean even if he makes a move
like h6 or he pushes one of his pawns
his king is already going to start
getting a little bit more weak right
right so I think she'll play it based on
what I saw yesterday and based on the
the her her ability to remember ideas I
kind of think she's gonna play it but I
go here we go okay you're guessing the
moves very well here you go yeah I mean
it's kind of a compliment at your rating
to be able to guess 900 moves so you're
welcome well I mean I think more than
that for me it's not it's not so much
about guessing it's the fact that your
laugh is even funnier than that check me
oh my gosh oh oh my gosh oh my gosh oh
oh no no no no no no no whoa no no no um
Loosli nice job
she went for it it paid off
yes so we definitely finished this game
a little bit earlier than we had planned
but um huge shout out to the hall most
35,000 people watching foosley go for
this incredible
checkmate tactic that did actually pay
off so thanks so much everyone for being
here
Wow let's shock it once again big shot -
everybody's watching I actually watched
in several of the chats I I'm kind of
stunned
I'm not stunned that she won but I'm
stunned that literally what I showed her
actually uh actually like works I'm just
I'm stunned I'm really stunned that
literally exactly what I showed her play
it out so so it's just me well well you
saw into the future here I guess I mean
one thing then that just seems like a
really good coaching strategy is telling
the players some some tricks to go for
and also how to defend against some of
these basic checkmate ideas because if
you don't see them maybe they're not so
obvious I'm sure he's not gonna fall for
it a second time but the first time it's
a bit tricky mm-hmm right right but
that's it's incredible to see I think I
mean certainly since we are coaching
these players I think when you see
something you give someone some basic
idea or a plan to see it actually work
perfectly it's um it's it's really
amazing it shows it like for me at least
since I am doing a little bit of
coaching that I've done a good job
definitely soso foosley
takes three points for that win and she
will be joining us on the stream soon so
we'll actually be able to talk to her
and you you can maybe give her some
praise for remembering all of the
opening that you taught her hmm all
right
so I guess in the meantime we can look
over the game a little bit and just show
the audience where we think the first
mistakes were so is there a particular
point you would like to start off at yes
I think the first step is I'm really
curious if ear or despawned push because
to me the moves that he played up until
he pushed the pawn looks very normal
like something then I think he was
wearing his Hans Neiman the
International master and I see it's all
like this was normal and he played c4 so
I'm wondering if he had already looked
at this or if this was when he was kind
of on his own at this point in terms of
pushing this pawn because it just it
seems like a very surprising move to
play out of the blue when you played a
bunch of normal moves right it seems
like if it wasn't part of his
preparation maybe he thought he was
going for some type of tactic what would
you recommend that he tried instead of
I think the obvious move here would have
been to bring his bishop out on light
squares like Bishop f5 for example try
to mirror the white bishop and then try
to push the pawn up to e6 on the next
move and uh sorry just once I gonna have
to get back to the game who are we
falling
we are following Benjamin Bach and
Bulldog accidentally okay cuz I think I
was already following them so so just
give me a second but while I pull it up
can you maybe talk a little bit about
what general strategy advice you could
give to him to improve for his future
games
yeah I think the main thing is I didn't
I didn't like that it had a lack of flow
like the way he played burying the Queen
out was completely fine but it wasn't
based on a fundamental idea because you
generally want to bring your bishops out
your Knights out get your King out
center before we try to attack really
early with the Queen so it just felt
like he went for something that was it
was kind of like trying to cheese but if
your opponent has a basic idea of how to
set up against it then um then then it's
probably not gonna work and then I think
you get lost way too way too quickly in
terms of um in terms of trying to try
and figure out what to do alright well
thank you for sharing that chat we will
be back soon we are just cutting to a
small break thanks so much everybody for
being here
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and we are back everyone we are joined
by Foose Lee who just checkmated her
opponent in 13 moves as well as by her
proud coach Hikaru who actually taught
her a lot of those opening theory yes
hello hi it is I um Leslie or foosley
and I'm really happy right now
yeah congratulations that was amazing
Hikari you do you want to tell her what
you were saying during the game well I
mean in general I was just I was very
impressed by your ability to remember
the patterns kind of just to play the
same side up even though the orders were
different you basically remember the
general general stuff that I showed you
yesterday which as I think I hinted at
last I was just impressed by by your
ability to remember and then even once
you got to splish towards the end to
bring the Queen in attack which is very
very impressive game buddy thank you
I was um yeah I I literally knew nothing
about just like a week and a half ago
and I still don't know too much but that
lesson we crammed in a lesson yesterday
for like one hour where um Hikari taught
me the London opening I'm not sure
what's called isn't an opening or you
got it yeah and then so yeah so I was
really scared that I was going to see
like any different variation than what
he taught me and so when like the bishop
or there was a I couldn't make the hat
under the pawn hat I don't know we call
it a hat it's like all the triangle and
then I thought I couldn't get my Bishop
there so I got really scared in the
middle of it and then at the end I
almost couldn't remember how to close
the game so I thought I almost threw
there but it somehow worked yeah I mean
you remembered the important plan which
was going for the checkmate
after you brought your Queen out to play
Queen takes h7 did you expect that he
was gonna fall for the trap um the one
where he takes what was a trap the trap
was right before you checkmated him so
he didn't do anything to defend it oh
yeah
yeah no I didn't I didn't didn't really
realize I laid that trap I'm really
happy that it did that he played what he
did because then it I realized I had two
straight lines a lot of times when I was
trying to practice the shot people would
like counter it with like pawns in a
line against the bishop so I wouldn't
know
I work around it so when I saw that
there was an open line directly yet that
was great and then sometimes it's hard
to play against when they don't Castle
and so when he castled that was also
great
well loosely was this one of your you
first like chess competition games ever
yes yes ma'am this is the first I think
I have 20 games total and this is your
first win I think this is the most
spectacular start we've seen in a really
long time car what do you think her
prospects are if she continues playing
yeah I think it's it's amazing general
progress from all from all the players I
mean just see the way they take the
lessons and then apply them to the games
I think certainly if you if you do like
study more of these opening opening
sequences you're gonna be someone to
record be reckoned with in this
tournament maybe in future future events
as well yeah I think I'm playing against
voyboy
next so I have no clue how to play on
the black side so yeah we do have a
problem coming up but it's fine I'll
I'll study if anyone's open for a chess
lesson yeah that would be cool too but
if not I'll figure it out well I know
that key cargo and I will be around to
help and I'm sure there's a lot of
coaches that you just let us know I mean
it's been such a pleasure coaching some
of the streamers but for sure boy boy he
is the tournament favorite how how do
you see your strategy trying to defeat
such a heavyweight no pressure no no
yeah I mean we could go for like total
confusion you know he won't know how to
play against me if I play real random
and stuff so there is that strategy
other than that I think what it was
really nice okay so usually when I play
chess I have like I I'm like freaking
out because I don't have enough time and
then the timer gets in my head but this
having a specific opening was really
great for me because I was able to like
okay this is what's supposed to happen
this is what's supposed to happen and
when I would stop and think it'd be like
okay it was because he would do
something a little bit that would like
stop one of my moves but it's really
nice to have like a specific opening so
I'm gonna try to maybe have something
like that like learn and opening that's
my look I love it
car do you have any specific advice for
her against boy boy um no but I think in
general is just to try and have a simple
plan where you develop your pieces and
try to attack and I'm sure one of us
will probably giving her a lesson before
the next match so just basically to have
some kind of idea but I thought the game
today was what support was basically
more or less perfect and I think for the
first game in the event we're kind of
not expecting play of such a high level
so it's just very very impressive and
grabs on winning a gun thank you and
it's truly an honor to be the highest
ranked most points in the entire
competition it's truly amazing so yeah
actually I don't know I'm calling voyboy
the leader you're the only person in the
entire tournament with three points yeah
so thank you everyone and thank you guys
for having me it's been a really good
experience so far and if I drop out now
you know I'm technically undefeated so
now that is true but before you go we
talked a lot about the chest I know that
you're a variety streamer and you know
you've been streaming for quite some
time now can you share a little bit more
about your channel with the audience oh
sure yeah so um real quick TLDR I am a
streamer I started yeah I started five
years ago and then I start with League
of Legends but then I realized there's
other games in the world so I played
csgo and then from there I tried other
shooters and I realized I liked shooters
a lot more and then from there I Oh real
quick
I used to stream on Twitch when like you
weren't allowed to do just chatting or
like I remember there's like a timer and
it would say like if you weren't like
talking what's your rebel jeez yeah so I
got a warning back in the day for trying
to talk to my chat and like just like
you build my community and stuff but now
yeah it's great to be I see that I can
just do whatever so sometimes I just
chat and I play games I sing I do but
your varieties of um yeah and so that's
pretty much my channel I was a really
bad summary of my stuff but that's
because you have a lot going on thank
you so much
Loosli for joining us chat if you want
to check her out twitch.tv slash fool
see we have her name above her webcam
she is the tournament leader so you guys
should go show her some support and then
on that end I think we're going to show
the tournament
thank you once again all right thank you
Congrats bye thank you
okay so we have group a we are next
going to see Nate Hill versus voyboy
and moist critical versus hutch and yeah
so until then the games are probably
gonna start in about 30 minutes or so
right mm-hmm so I think on that note we
are going to look at the schedule as
well oh sorry actually the show is
starting again in two minutes from now
nope that is the break okay we're gonna
cut to break and we'll be back shortly
see you guys soon
and we are joined now by Iran who you
know may have had a rough start but it's
just the first game he can still qualify
so thank you so much for joining us yeah
what up what up what up
oh man see this is like chess players
weren't cool in school you threw me off
with that one I'm not gonna lie what
with the what up it's just ya know we're
you know I'm just teasing so we wanted
to take a look at the game because uplay
to move that was was kind of cool and
tactical looking and we were wondering
if you had memorized some of the opening
moves when you pushed your Queen side
pawn on move six with c4 did you have a
trap in mind or was this I was talking
my coach and we predicted of like the
first 12 moves that she was going to do
and I was expecting her to bring her
Queen there instead of pushing her pawn
forward one and I was going to attack
but she didn't do it and it just blew
everything off and I didn't know what to
do from there
ah that's fair so you continued with the
plan that you had originally been taught
by your coach it makes sense if your
opponent deviates a little bit tricky so
you had planned her first 13 moves you
said yep alright well do you think that
strategy was helpful or do you think
maybe in the future you're gonna adapt
it a little although I lost so I don't
think it helped me very much I'm
probably gonna change it up all right
fair enough
so so then on move Queen h5 do you think
you played too quickly to miss a
checkmate tactic or what happened there
stupid I don't know I messed up I don't
know it happens it happens to everybody
we're sorry to see it there and you know
I mean it's always tough to do any type
of commentary after a loss I think you
car can also comment on that a little
bit yeah I think it's very difficult but
I felt that you played you understood
the base of where you're trying to do
just got a little bit caught off guard
and and it is the first game of the
events there still are many more games
left because I can still qualify I I
think you I looking at your group I
think you have a chance because you have
to play against an eighth Hill who I
think you're a little
better than so yeah you have competitive
games coming up I think it's definitely
possible yeah right one game player I
cannot no way
well at least you have you know as a the
next goal to continue but regardless I
mean there's gonna be both the winners
and a consolation bracket so you're
gonna get more games and can compete for
prizes regardless cool which I'll you
know at least is some silver lining
there but you know maybe we can switch a
little bit from from the chests topic
since this was a tough game I know that
you you do a lot of different variety
can you talk to us a bit about your
stream I get bullied for a living that's
pretty but I come online my chat they
trash talk me for about six seven hours
every single day we play some games i
dial out in the game that's pretty much
it anything you want to say to trash
talk your chat back just one time they
made me I can't shoot
I can't trash like them oh there's so
much there's so much love for your
community I really respect it it's a
very humble attitude to have thank you
well thank you so much for for coming on
with us we're gonna just look again at
today's results and are there any last
shoutouts you want to give your channel
or some cool upcoming events we can tell
people if they want to come check you
out other than that you know seven hours
of bullying that's okay alright well on
that end let's take a look at today's
results okay so as you guys know we did
Sifu Slee taking the win in this first
game up next we're going to see Nate
Hill versus voyboy hikaru it's gonna be
a 700 versus a 1700 you will have any
comments on that
yeah I think I think this this first
matchup probably as you look the
schedule will be the closest match up on
this first day of the event but I would
say Nate Hill from what I've seen he is
one of those players who seems to
understand coordination quite well in
trying to use pieces to make attacks so
he could surprise I think the best
chance that he's gonna have in terms of
making a surprise like a surprise
victory or not not not being defeated is
if he can get ahead on the clock and
maybe and put voyboy on pressure where
voile doesn't have so much time
I think it's certainly gonna be an
uphill battle but anything can happen
yeah I've been coaching Nate and he's
actually also very good at spotting
tactics I think the biggest difficulty
for him is just gonna be a lack of chess
experience obviously voyboy has been
playing for a lot longer but Nate does
like playing quickly so you know we're
gonna look for that and see how he
handles a tough opponent we can also
talk about voyboy because well he's one
of the best league of legend players out
there and he's also the highest rated in
the tournament I think his nickname is
kid genius he's the boy genius the boy
genius
okay sorry and and had another
interesting fact about him he carved he
had a really high SAT score you want to
take a guess at it
well he's he's young so I think what
that means is that he did it when it was
icy I'm doing it out of 2,400 yeah I'm
so old when I did the SAT I think it was
1,600 and now it's like 24 so I'm
guessing it's probably something like 23
95 or something almost he was 2,300
which is I think like Oh like 95
percentile or something insane so really
really impressive stuff there yeah and
yeah we're so we're gonna go show some
of his clips and yeah let's transition
to that now or actually we're not gonna
show some of those clips we're gonna go
back to looking at the groups that are
going to be coming up next so we have
group a group b group c group d today
we're going to be looking at group a
tomorrow I believe is group B so we have
the schedule out there if there's any
particular stream where you guys want to
check out until then we're gonna go to
break and we'll be back shortly
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and we are back everyone we are actually
watching voyboy shout out to all 40,000
of you guys we really appreciate it it's
good to see that voyboy is training a
little bit Hikari do you want to talk a
little bit about what you've seen as his
chest skills so far yeah so I've been
very fortunate that I have had the
opportunity to play play play the boy
genius a couple of times we played some
games where I was blindfold we also
discussed his general his general
upbringing how he got into chess I think
he was much younger he took some lessons
when I was young and there was a funny
story about how I don't know if you were
familiar with the story but his his
mother wanted him to be well this is a
great one be be be a good chest for like
Daniel narrowed its key which of course
is it's pretty funny I think of the time
being it wasn't that that strong but
certainly certainly to have your mom
compare you to someone who goes on to
become a very strong Grandmaster it's
pretty funny to put it mildly
because there are extremely high
expectations for anybody yeah that's
definitely big shoes to fill in but you
know maybe his mom could be proud
because although he's not Daniel Niro
disky he's one of the best league of
legend players in the world and he he
might end up being one of the pogchamp
champions so that's also a title to
strive for here yeah I think certainly
is one of the favorites there there's
several people who have been really
working very hard I think at the moment
he has the highest rating by probably
about a hundred points or a little over
100 points so it's gonna be interesting
to see what happens but I do expect him
to start off strong here in this first
match definitely and who do you think
some of his biggest competitors will be
if I look overall I think the biggest
competitors probably for sure hutch and
box box or the two guys who are the
closest after that I would say possibly
forest and although his ability to avoid
getting tilted is gonna be is gonna be
very critical because as all the bys
know he um he's had some issues with
that over the past couple of days when
he's playing against some people just
like he loses focus for a couple of
moves and bad things tend to happen but
I think forsen is one of the one of the
strongest players as well so I would say
those are the top four but I do
like somebody to surprise and possibly
be a contender as well fair enough well
I see chat going wild as you said that
but hey it's a good thing because if he
learns how to deal with the rage quits
and chess you know that's a skill that
might even pass on to the other games he
plays right exactly yeah but once
another thing that I've said on my shirt
a few times I find very interesting is
it seems like the League of Legends
players are the ones who have the most
natural ability just sort of sort of
buckle down and study the game of chess
during this period between one the
invites were sent out and the actual
competition occurring so I think it's
certainly um it's interesting to note to
note the way that it seems like it's
pretty Universal at all the league
players are really working very hard
well that's interesting do you think
it's related to some of the mechanics
you learn in league or just because it's
a game that you need to grind a lot of
hours and to get better right so I mean
I actually was having a conversation
with voyboy the other day about this and
I think what he was saying is that
essentially because you have to grind a
lot just to get better you keep playing
over and over and over again that is
just sort of a natural ability that you
get you get used to it and just tends to
be the same way where it's it's all
about just practicing over and over
again playing games doing puzzles and
I'm trying to improve so I think maybe
it's not more than anything to see the
ability to get to keep doing it over and
over and over again
got it well speaking of things were
doing over and over we want to remind
people of the format because I know a
lot of people are coming in and out so
for pogchamp for all of the streamers
the players are split into four groups
of four we are seeing one of those
groups today group a and the players are
doing a single round-robin you might be
like what is this chest Girish I have no
idea what a round-robin is and honestly
if I don't play chess I won't have
either it just means that they're going
to play every other player in their
bracket at least once and the format is
going to be ten minutes with a five
second increment we're incentivizing
people to play for a win so you get
three points for a win and one for a
draw
usually in traditional chess tournaments
you get one point for a win and a half
for a draw so winds are going to be
three times as valuable instead of two
times as valuable the top two in each
group so there's four people in a group
the top two
go to the championship bracket at the
bottom to go to the consolation bracket
that's important because it means that
we are going to see these streamers
multiple times even if they finish last
in their first group and each eight
player bracket will play down to a
winner so we could look a little bit at
the brackets it obviously helps to have
some visuals for those so we are going
to have the the winner of Group A go
against the group B second place to
produce a winner there and you can see
that for the following groups as well
with group 2 group D and Group C and
let's take a look as well at the
participants so we got all of the
streamers here we have a box box who is
a league of Legends player and he is the
player Hikaru actually put in as one of
the contenders for winning this all
because he's closest in rating to boy
boy and to hutch but he has also been
grinding so many hours of chess he used
to be about 1,500 when he was younger
and I think he's probably gonna become
at least sixteen seventeen hundred
strength by the end of this game we also
have critical who you actually had on
your show as well do you want to talk a
little bit about him yeah so I think I
had Moyes critical charlie he's also
penguins penguins z0 on on youtube very
interesting guy he's played he played
chess I think when he was younger now
he's more of a sort of rise room does a
lot of lot of things on YouTube and
twitch and I just going back to the game
I know he's taking quite a few lessons
he had a lesson with me I too get a
lesson with narrowed its key as well so
I'm just looking forward to see seeing
what Charlie is learned and how well he
can put it put it to use and be in a
practical game situation right and we
also have a Rob we just talked to we
just saw him play his game he's a
variety slash just chatting streamer
forsen who is known for hearthstone but
he's actually been watching your games
throughout he car he's been trying to
guess the move alongside Robert yeah I
think for since another guy who he
really wants to win the competition I
think when you tend to be good in
various various things especially like
in Starcraft and Horace Tony I think I
think you played in twitch rivals for
hearthstone as well I think I think you
just said competive
nature you want to keep improving and
trying to do your best I think the
faculty has so many fans out there who
are who are spamming the chat right now
it just speaks to speaks to how much
everybody is interested what he's doing
I think he's one of the guys who has the
best was one of the best opportunities
to create an upset and when win the
whole thing
absolutely foosley we also saw today
she's a variety streamer she memorized
the lines that Hikaru gave to her today
and we saw her check made her opponent
in just 13 moves in her like 21st or
something like that chess game ever I
mean that's a huge accomplishment so
shout out to her there we also have
hutch who is one of the best Call of
Duty players and one of the most
experienced chess players he also does
quite a bit of politics on Twitch and
it's pretty unique because you don't
have that many people who focus on it on
twitch as Foose Lee mentioned when she
started doing just chatting it wasn't
even allowed on Twitch so we've
definitely seen a huge evolution there
Ludwig who is another variety streamer I
stopped by his stream yesterday and it
was hilarious he introduced himself has
an international master Hikaru yeah and
he kept on going and like making him
fancy terms like oh and I'm gonna do
some like fanciful fee and get doing
with this move and it just completely
unrelated so I haven't laughed that hard
at chess in a really long time would
highly recommend you guys check out his
stream we have Nate Hill who's also
going to be playing today he's a
fortnight player what do you take on a
Rob saying he doesn't want to lose to a
fortnight streamer um I mean I think
certainly uh there's a perception that
if you play for it I guess that maybe I
don't know maybe it's just not a game
that requires a lot of skill perhaps you
have to be very young to play it I'm not
quite sure where that's going but at any
rate I think certainly um Nate Nate is a
guy who I believe he has a degree in
mathematics he graduated college so I
think it's it's a weird it's weird
juxtaposed when you think about for
tonight players and I think Nate being a
I think he's still professional for
tonight player he is one of the oldest
Fortnight players out there I think he's
like 24 maybe or 25 which I mean it's
crazy to say this but that is very much
on the older side for a game like for
tonight so I think I think in general
maybe she's a perception that to play
for tonight perhaps it's not um it's
it's one of those games where he maybe
it's just all about mechanics and things
as opposed to having to think a lot but
certainly need his natives very smart
guy he's been been learning a lot at a
very quick rate with chess so just I'm
really curious to see how he performs
cuz he is I think one of the only
fortnight players right I think as for
as well but one of the two Fortnite
players exactly and I agree with you I
mean I've seen the way he does his
calculations I was really impressed I
know he also had a background in
modeling before he turned into a pro
Fortnight player and I think it's even
more difficult to become a fro Pro
Fortnight player the older you are
because you know your reaction time and
things like that actually tend to
decrease so the fact that he's able to
compete I you know only compliments to
say they're right we also have NIM he's
a variety streamer and I think you did a
lesson with him right here oh I did I
did a lot with NIM I think it was
yesterday morning I did a lot of lessons
yesterday but I did a lesson with NIM me
Austria and he certainly is one of these
guys where he sees a lot of the ideas
but he attends to be pretty slow in
terms of utilizing them but I would say
he is one of the players who I think is
is a dark horse maybe make that make the
champions bracket and possibly finish
like in the top two or talked for
because he is capable of coming up with
plans and following through with them so
I think you certainly if he plays and he
you know operation Nimrod works he's
certainly gonna be a very tough opponent
certainly and we also have Papa plate he
is a German variety streamer although I
know that he sometimes mixes English
swearing with his German so you know
which is the language when it counts
he's it's Papa pelota I think or
something it's not plate but there are
German people watching I'm sure sorry
can you say that again he card I think
it's it's platta like that is for a
platter it's like the UH I think that's
what I was told yesterday so so yeah no
I appreciate I appreciate you correcting
piggy on that and we also have a slicker
he is a counter-strike player and he
just recently got signed on Team Liquid
he is hilarious he has been out there
given the the chess players branding
advice
for example he was jokingly telling Hans
that he should become the edgy streamer
and get like a little Queen tattoo oh
wow okay that's uh I had not heard that
before that's certainly an original idea
slicker I think it's one of the guys
who's he he's very funny I mean but he's
very out-there as well and so it's very
interesting to see his take on
especially on the chest world I think I
saw a couple of the clips that he did on
on I am Hans Neiman and they definitely
were we're different than what I think
I'm used to seeing but he's a great
entertainer and one of the most popular
streamers and Savannah I think a lot of
people are curious to see how he does
and does he sort of the the
light-hearted trash-talking that that's
gonna happen I know I was watching him
play Moe yasuo in a match and the
trash-talking between them was really
really funny yeah I saw that game he was
down eight pieces and he managed to
stalemate with his fighting spirit so it
was pretty entertaining dog we also have
swifter actually he's the other
fortnight's streamer I guess we should
have mentioned that I know that he's
also competitive Call of Duty so that's
probably more of what I thought him as
and he has trained with Grandmaster
Daniel narrowed its key so we'll see if
the lessons are going to be useful
boy boy League of Legends we've already
talked about him at length and we are
going to see him against Nate he'll up
next so I will move on to choco bars the
League of Legends dreamer maybe you can
talk a bit more butter since you guys
did a lesson recently yeah so I think
Janet certainly she was known for League
of Legends I think lately she's played
much more TFT team teamfight tactics and
then not now playing a little bit of
chess as well certainly someone who's
had a lot of experience with twitch
rivals events I think she was part of
the winning team to the League of
Legends which rivals last year two years
ago but someone who's also pretty new to
trust like Foose Li like swift door and
Anita Hill as well but again I think
anything can happen just just like like
what like I did it foosley try to give
some basic opening advice and and
hopefully it works out but again I think
everybody is working really hard they're
studying a lot and everybody has their
opening strats they're gonna come
prepared within it's a matter of whether
whether they work or don't work right
and we'll just move on to the last two
streamers as well xq c Hikaru and xu C
have done you know so many hilarious
collabs
XQ cease to be a formal professional
overwatch player he's now a full-time
streamer with the most watched in this
entire group you guys have a fantastic
relationship any words you want to add
yeah I think everybody there there's so
many people I mean I since since I since
I do have a chat open of course shot
spam X you see all while you're at it um
but but yeah I think certainly the most
entertaining the guy who got this whole
this whole this whole thing started in
many ways by doing the collaboration
shows me and it took off from there it
had its own life I remember it I saw
some comment that said something along
lines of this xqc altered the the
timeline or something what's happening
now she'd never happen or it's like a
butterfly effect I think in many ways he
deserves a lot of credit for this and
even if he's not the strongest where the
fact that he's raised the profile of the
game of chess by playing it on stream
doing the collaborations with me it's
it's really amazing to see I need oh he
deserves a lot of credit so just really
interested to see how he performs
obviously I obviously has played more
chess I think on stream or just online
in the last month and I think anybody
else and I don't think it's even close
so hopefully he'll remember some of the
things I'll be able to slow it down a
little bit trust his instincts because
he has very good instincts and and he
might he might be a threat action to
make the champions bracket as well if he
can beat Yasuo
alright well speaking of yeah so he is a
league of Legends streamer and I
actually did a lesson with him yesterday
and he told me how he had he'd only been
playing for three weeks I've never seen
anyone pick up the game as quickly as I
felt that he did during our lesson so
really impressed with his performance so
far he said that he watches a ton of
chess videos before he goes to bed so
clearly that information is sinking in
but on that note let's just preview the
next match so we're gonna have a void by
with the black pieces against Nate Hill
boy boy League of Legends Nate Hill
fortnight
the the rating difference is definitely
pretty large here but as he Carver
mentioned you know if nate is able to
play relatively quickly he does have
good mechanics he might be able to pull
off an upset
and I I'm sorry go ahead I was gonna say
I think in general it seems like he he's
pretty good at the puzzles so I don't I
don't expect a surprise but if he can if
he kind of if you can play relatively
quickly there is some chance actually
what are the colors by the way I Nate
Hill is gonna be playing with the white
pieces okay so I think the Faculty's
playing with white means there's more of
a possibility of a surprise because I
think when you play with the white
pieces it's it's harder for your
opponent to cheesy with black and I I do
think that that if he can get out of the
opening stage again that he'll probably
get a game I don't expect him to pull
off an upset but again you never know if
if if boy boys a little bit slow
something something could happen and I
know we'll just we'll just see it and
that's why you play the game as the
result is not predetermined anybody can
win right and even just beyond that if
he's able to hold his own against voyboy
it'll already be very impressive to you
know try to guess how he's gonna do in
the overall tournament on that note you
guys we are going to cut to break and
we'll be back shortly see you guys soon
and shout outs off almost 45,000 of you
guys thanks so much
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back everyone we are about to
see voyboy
twitch TV / boy boy League of Legends
streamer about 1700s so the tournament
favorite take on Nate Hill he is a
fortnight's streamer and well maybe we
can switch to Nate's card as we say this
he's a fortnight's streamer he's been
relatively new to chess but he's been
picking it up very quickly he's
definitely the underdog here so let's
see how long he can fight boy boy off
and maybe even try to create an upset in
the second round of the pawnshops
tournament yeah I tend to agree I think
Nate Nate is one of those guys and this
I think is why chess has become so
popular on Twitch as well as Nate is one
of these people who clearly he played
when he was much younger even if it
wasn't competitively he played some
whether as his parents or with other
kids at school he learned the game of
mahjongg I think the fact that he's
coming back to it now I think certainly
helps because he's picking up things
much quicker than if he it was starting
simply from from scratch and starting
from from zeros so I'm just looking
forward to seeing seeing seeing how he
plays as someone who is new to chess
hasn't played much and just hopefully
you can play well and and make it
competitive that's a great way to put it
we have the game starting in about a
minute but before we go there we'll just
remind you guys of the format quickly so
this is the first group that is playing
and each player in the group will play
against each other
we got three points for a win one point
for a draw 0 for a loss and both players
will move on or all four players will
move on to either the winner's bracket
or the consolation bracket on that note
he card do you have any tips for players
who are facing somebody a lot stronger
of them in rating in terms of what their
strategy should be yeah I mean I think
what I would say in terms of strategy is
try to play something where they can get
out get out of this opening stage of the
game without being significantly behind
being down by rook ting being down by
Queen where they're a big material
disadvantage I think if that happens
there is the possibility possibility
that lightning will strike and their
opponent even through much higher rated
can make mistake and they will be able
to to Surprise them and get a victory I
think that's the most critical thing is
the big differences is the pattern
recognition of the fact that at the
start of the game
who are stronger we'll have some sort of
opening strategy just to just to get to
the middle part of the game immediately
absolutely and that's building on the
point excuse me on the point that you
said earlier about how the fact that
nate is starting off with the white
pieces that's a bit of an advantage for
him just because he gets to decide where
the opening is going right so I think
that's that's a that's very favorable
for him certainly starting with with the
white pieces against voyboy and I don't
know since I since I haven't coached it
I had no idea what is the opening
strategies are you probably yeah he's
gonna start with E for and I'm following
the game now okay so I guess against a
start so I think boy boy's been looking
at the Sicilian defense so I think it's
gonna be four c500 no no Nate and I
haven't even begun to counter the
Sicilian I know I mean we were focused
on you know opening principles but hey
he's bringing out his pieces okay he
knows that he wants to develop his
pieces
okay but he brought the night out okay
he brought the night out though this is
good he brought the night out or he's
bringing the bishop out okay this is
basic opening principles that's what I
told him to not worry too much about
theory since he's about like 650 700
rating and just to worry like capture
the get the center develop your pieces
try to castle and he's doing that so I'm
very good start this is a very good
start very classical just develop the
knight the bishop and get the King out
of the center um I think this next move
is gonna be one of the core okay please
de three very good move by Nate for
someone who has not played much chest
this is this is actually very good story
I think for a boy boy it's gonna be
interesting so I think boy boy knows
he's the big favorite he expects to win
but trying to figure out whether to try
to do something very right away or play
something more more traditional is gonna
make a is gonna make a difference ok
Knight c3
I like that natives playing very solid
here so he's developing all his pieces
first he does like to play aggressively
so I think as soon as we see all of his
minor pieces develop he's gonna start
going for the pawn pushes yeah so I
think here's the one trick in this
position is that Nate has to stop this
Bishop from coming to g4 by pushing the
pawn to h3 I think it's a very hard
thing to see as a beginner pushing a
pawn on the side of the board like that
so that's my only concern in the
position
but okay goes Queenie to not not
objectively not a terrible move
unfortunately it's probably not gonna
work out very well but I like the fact
that he is developing the pizzas still
because even though even if I mean even
though I think he's really gonna lose
the game if he follows the principles
when he plays against other people at
his rating level or he plays against
people and say one of the one of the
brackets he's gonna be evilly mashup and
following this principle these
principles will make a make a big
difference going forward right so here
I'm interested to see if he's gonna go
for h3 to try to get out of the pin in
our lessons we talked a lot about that
kind of idea just to not be annoyed by
pins to keep the pressure on cuz 95
looks pretty annoying here right
well 94 is also a huge threat as well
right but both the night moves are very
very dangerous so I think the best mover
white hairs probably move the Queen up
but again it sort of violates the
opening principles this would be five is
another good move but they sort of
violate the principle so I think it's
gonna be a little bit hard for Nate to
come up with that with the correct move
but he is using his time which is good
to see the fact that he's using his time
and he's thinking he's not rushing into
making a move is very important okay
Bishop III not a bad move
I knew this 95 move is still a problem
but but it's not it's not necessarily
lost yet which is which is good it's
it's still with him excuse me within the
margin where it still remains again
right he's he's surviving the opening
although it does seem like he's gonna
come out of it in a slightly worse
position right and I think what the most
important thing goes if you're facing
off against what these guys who's much
better than you are as long as you get
to follow the principles and you don't
lose immediately that's the biggest
thing that's the biggest boost of
confidence you get can get and voyboy
actually did not play 95 so if nate
plays h3 here he's probably still in the
game potentially um whether he'll play
h3 I don't know I think it's very hard
concept as a beginner to grasp because
you don't really understand pushing the
pawns on the side of the board to attack
pieces but it may it may happen we'll
see yeah so he played Bishop b5 I think
it's just related to what you mentioned
it's hard once you're out of the opening
to try to come up with some kind of plan
here
on the bright side at least 95 is not
going to attack his bishop twice and
maybe cause some isolated pond sorry
double ponds mm-hmm right so I expect
why would it play 95 but he's thinking
quite a bit here so I'm kind of curious
actually I'm really curious to see what
uh what what happens because he's
thinking quite a bit right cuz 95 is the
most intuitive move here if he sees the
threat with the pin and if he doesn't
see this right with the pin then maybe
he won't get as much of an advantage out
of the opening as we expected right oh
and boy boy does not take advantage okay
please Queen b6 so now nature obviously
capture the knight here I think this is
absolutely critical in order to stay in
the game keep the material balance where
it's the same I do expect me to take the
knight simply because he sees the Queen
is there attacking the bishop it's
always like a very natural move
especially as a beginner player to to
try to exchange some of the some of the
material so that there's less material
on the board so you can sort of you can
see more of the the moves and this is
where I worry about you know as a coach
when you talk about principles I told
them how you know it's important to keep
the bishop pair on unless you're
creating some kind of weakness or if the
position is open but maybe yeah maybe
he's trying to keep his vision fair here
right so he's trying to keep the bishops
again 95 is a good move I'm a little bit
surprised that boy boy is not playing it
there's a little bit of a sign I would
say a weakness I think some of the other
top players so I'm sure watching like
specifically box box inside I'm 100%
sure he's watching 99% I'm not gonna
look for sure that he is but I'm sure
the Box box this is a sort of idea that
box would spot right away so I think for
someone like box box if he's watching
he's gonna sort of be sensing that maybe
this is already something like boy boy
isn't seeing all the all the ideas and
and just doing the scouting ahead of
time for the before the next bracket and
another impressive factor is given the
the rating difference between these two
players nate is actually up on time whoa
and and boy boy is actually helping me
with a plan that he wanted to play
record that we wanted him to play for
garlis so yeah so i think nature should
take tonight again they're only really
our two squares
where the bishop can go I guess box box
isn't watching this live but I know that
he's gonna see that he's gonna look at
the game later that's just kind of guy
Albert is and it's not somebody should
clip what he car said and send it to him
because box box has been taking this
very seriously right right so I think um
I do think that neat will take tonight
most likely it's kind of a little bit
awkward or treating this bishop I feel
as a beginner because you want you want
to get rid of pieces like you like
capturing opponents pieces okay plays 85
unfortunately this gives away a pawn um
but it's still not completely lost II I
think there already took like mu 15
maybe a little bit further than 1100
it's only move 11 okay it's all like
it's close to the middle game but the
fact that he hasn't given away a lot of
material I think shows that the lessons
you've done with with me certainly have
helped him improve because against
someone who's this strong in the way
that uh in the way that boy boy is the
fact that he's not ahead by a lot more
material it's it's it's a very good sign
yeah well I appreciate that as you know
just a coach and seeing people but now
he did lose lose upon and voyboy strong
so I'm not surprised that he saw that
and now nate is actually gonna have to
he's gonna start to have some trouble so
hopefully he does see the threat on his
bishop and he does move it away
otherwise then it will be lost for him
mm-hmm I think it's it's already very
dangerous but there is one glimmer of
hope which is that he moves to Bishop
back to a four here on the block were to
capture the pawn of b2 okay yeah we
spoke too soon right for the idea I was
gonna say was if you it was Bishop a4
takes you could move the bishop back and
then try to trap the Queen but
unfortunately I think it's it's it's
probably going a little bit downhill
kind of kind of quickly here
unfortunately yeah and I mean I think
that's a fair point because learning
more middle game strategy takes longer
than getting the opening principles down
right exactly so I think that's kind of
the that's the hardest part is like Nate
develop the pieces but then there were
no sort of open files to use his rooks
on and I think understanding how to move
the pieces and then the middle game just
move it's it's not something that comes
natural unless you played quite a bit of
chess
and so yeah but it's still quite good
though I'm quite happy to see that Nate
got to this point in the game without
being down significant material so it's
it's a good sign
yeah I was gonna say that maybe voyboy
may have fallen for the trap where if he
took on b5 earlier than Nate would have
had a fork on c7 but boy boy did
calculate that out and now the b2 pond
looks like it's going to hang as well
right and I think because of that it's
it's already one night
barring some kind of huge mistake from
from boy boy okay but he plays c4 okay
this is gonna be an interesting point
too because here if boy boy moves the
Queen to like b4 then Y can go Bishop d2
mm-hmm and you you attack the Queen and
the knight so or if he takes on b2 then
you can trade off the Queen and take the
knight right so I think it's still it's
still winning if you drop the Queen back
to B since I am quite curious to see
what voyboy does here okay drop it to b6
he did find that and I guess there
there's some tricky plans that are still
wrong here ideas like I was gonna say b4
the problem with Queen d2 is now we
might seem Knight b3 and more material
hanging right but actually I do even
though the position is lost I do like
that he saw the move as a way of trying
to attack the knight so even even though
it's even though it's of course not the
best move the fact that he sees a way of
trying to attack the knight it's it's
very good it's it's a good sign because
when he plays against someone his own
level people are not gonna be seeing all
these moves and it should give him it
should it should help him a lot
unfortunately in this situation he's
just he's kind of overmatched a little
bit right and it is hard to understand
what a player strength is when you pair
them against such a heavy favorite so I
am curious as you mentioned to see how
he'll do you know against someone like
Iran mm-hmm right that'll be I I still
think Iran is probably the favorite
against Nate but you know you never know
I think a lot depends on what the
players learn and how comfortable they
feel with the position they get right
right at the start of the game right and
huge shout out 50,000 of you guys
watching thanks so much everyone for
being here
show your support - you know these these
streamers from a wide array of
backgrounds who are giving Ches a try so
that's definitely a very positive part
of this event okay so what is queen bee
woman sorry yes they both have six
minutes still so yeah I mean I think
it's gonna be very hard oonh eight with
the pre-move I like that I like the
style I think yeah I think he pre moves
- I think he's switching his strategy
and he's saying you know I might not be
better on the board here but at least he
has that speed going for him hopefully
you can trade Queens yeah and I think
it's actually very important that he
just basically tries to move fast now I
thought that it will work but I like the
idea trying to switch it up a little bit
and actually Nate doesn't I think I'm
looking at his expression I don't think
he realizes that the bishop can capture
I don't think he realizes that uh that
the the heavy sniper on jisub just
captures the Queen on on b2 but but now
I does see it because he thought
quizzical look for a second where he
didn't understand what boy-boy had done
oh that moment of the excitement when
you think he might get back into the
game it's so cruel to have it grabbed
away right right but I still I'm very
impressed that even though he's losing
the game he didn't get checkmate and his
king was safe and there are certainly
some good good fundamentals that he is
shown in this game so what advice would
you have to Nate for his upcoming games
based on what you've seen so far I mean
I think first of all is just just to
have a basic set up that he wants to
play where where he feels comfortable
where he can play the first six or seven
moves and not worry specifically about
how the opponent reacts um but I think
for the most part just remembering how
to develop these pieces and trying to
trying to create these open open files
for the rooks it looks to me like and
actually even this one for example
playing ninety two is a good move
obviously it's way behind so it doesn't
matter but it's a good fundamental move
avoiding this this capture and keeping
more piece on the board and I have
noticed with a lot of these top not top
players with a lot of these streamers
they have issues with these backwards
moves where they move Knights where they
move bishops backwards to retreat or try
to move to another square and the fact
that need has done this is is actually
quite impressive because this has been
the number one thing I've noticed as
most the streamers have an issue with
these backward sort of moves right and
that was a good move
since he's down material he doesn't want
to trade and also avoid boy would have
traded then he would have doubled up his
pawns as well so right so I fighting
yeah I like what we're seeing I mean
unfortunately I think boy boy has this
game in the bag now because the pawns
are positives coming straight down the
board but still it's it's very it's very
it's very good to see that someone who's
so new to the game in such a short time
is still showing some good general
understanding of how to play right and
in addition to his try to play fast
strategy what else do you think somebody
in his shoes might try to save a game
where he's down at rook um well I think
the first thing is just try and keep
Queens on the poor I think without the
Queens it's very very hard if he if he
had maybe a queen on the board there
would still be some hopes of a surprise
but unfortunately without Queens on the
board it's just it's it's it's really
just it's not enough pieces to attack
the King with it's very hard to get the
knight or the bishop near the king
so unfortunately just not enough
material right I mean even if there's a
pawn on e5 let's say I guess he can try
for some stuff like Bishop h6 and
bringing the knight to f6 but it's just
not enough he doesn't have enough pieces
to create any type of counter attack
here right exactly yeah so just talk
tough game tough start I think for Nate
but still not not bad considering he's
playing that's one of the absolute
favorites in in the tournament right and
it's always hard to start off with a
difficult pairing but at least the next
person he plays will seem a lot easier
that is also true right when you start
playing it's the top player in your
bracket than the next couple of games
will fill significantly easier because
you're not going to be overmatched right
and here hopefully he'll make one pawn
push at some point because what we
notice is that he has all those three
pawns near his King and he might end up
falling for background-check me although
boy boy honestly he's playing so well at
this point he knows that he's up and
he's just simplifying he has that pass
ball and he's gonna bring in the rook so
yeah so boy boy boys being very
traditional here he's just playing
specifically to he's playing
specifically to to exchange your rooks
take all the forces off the board and
just adjust just attack and I
I really like it it's very very good so
from boy boys game so far I know you
mentioned that you were surprised that
he didn't say c95 but other than that do
you feel like he's been performing at
his 1700 level yeah III think so far
it's been good the main thing I've
noticed is voidable he's very good at
the tactical puzzles but his issue is in
the opening phase I think if he gets out
of this opening set like first 10 to 15
moves he's very very strong but I think
some people will will be able to will be
able to trick him there possibly makes
sense and Nate does play h3 this is a
good move he's attacking the bishop at
the same time and he's also making space
for his King so that wasn't actually
that easy of a move for him to see so
pretty pretty good call on his end yeah
yeah I I like what nate is doing i mean
even though he's way behind he's still
playing moves to attack certain pieces
and it's it's just a very good sign even
even though even though the results not
in doubt he's still making still making
moods that are logical right they're
just gonna get increasingly more
difficult here just because there's
really you know it's hard to defend when
you when you're down but hey he finds
Bishop g5 he's looking towards e7 I like
his style
yeah I like I like what he's doing in
general just trying to find the
weaknesses in the black position even
with only the pitch from the night
trying to attack the pawns or the bishop
like the bishop on a1 with the night so
I like I like what he's doing it's it's
just very good and I think in the in the
later rounds when he's playing as people
who are his rating it's gonna pay it'll
pay dividends for sure voyboy definitely
not his rating he instantly protects
Issa and he gives him no options for
counter play and then he takes his phone
just merciless here yeah I think I mean
boy boy I can tell from the way he's
playing this game he's being super safe
just trying not to let Nate have any
tricks at all just exchange the rooks
exchange as many of the forces as he
can't just taking a very professional
very very professional approach this
first game and I'm really just not
giving ate anything so it's pretty tough
but but this is why voyboy is one of the
favorites in the event yeah he certainly
is and I see chat moving really rapidly
as well you guys are putting quite a few
emotes there it seems like they are
to create a force in space in the chat
as well as some of the excuses dude
comments yeah
X you see L always X you see L but yeah
I see I see the buyers I see the X you
see like just everything everything it's
fantastic see I think there are
something like 90,000 people watching
chat's across the channel so it's really
amazing and big shout out to all these
people who've been a part of it I think
certainly as I've mentioned on my own
stream this event would not have been
possible without the big streamer is
getting interested in chess and then
also many of their communities sort of
coming up with this idea and suggesting
it and and turning it into a reality so
I think everybody should should be
commended for being a part of this right
because it is always difficult to pick
up any type of new game and chess is one
of those where a lot of people also feel
more pressure because you know people
joconi he'll offer to draw offered
another draw oh no well you can see for
boy boys look on its face you could tell
that into the odds it's a good joke here
okay well I'll try to tell me this
position right right but but it's good
also to see like for example I think
with this match you can see like they're
both in a good mood they're having fun
with it and I think that's what you want
to see at the other day obviously if
you're in the Champions bracket it will
be more serious but the fact that
they're there laughing and having a good
time I think it's uh it's it's really
nice to see right no cuz voyboy is
laughing too and usually when you see a
chess player who gets a draw for in a
loss in a winning position they get a
little bit annoyed but you know when
it's it's more friendly and it's newer
players it's nice to see everyone
exactly yeah and I think that's
fantastic see it's not getting too
competitive yet and and it's early stage
surely for the people who are new to
have a good time and and enjoy it that's
that's the most important thing by far
well Nate isn't giving up so you as you
mentioned at the start you said it would
be a good result
if Nate was able to survive the opening
would you consider getting out of the
opening just a one minor piece down a
success for Nate I think it's a big
success especially considering the fact
you did not show them any sort of setup
against it right like you didn't show
him to bring the night in the bishop out
did you not against the Sicilian no I
just gave him basic opening principles
right so I think the fact that he
brought out two pieces very quickly like
that it's it's it's a good sign because
it shows that even though he was out of
his comfort zone he still found a way to
develop the pieces and and I think if
someone can do that when they're
surprised it's gonna bode well for the
future games because the game between
food Slaney Rob was certainly I think
one of the very few games where an
opening was shown to one of the players
and it literally occurred on the board
almost exactly as you scripted it per se
but if you look at um most these games
you're gonna be surprised people are
gonna play something that distracts you
on one sided poor or the other side of
the board and so the fact that you came
up with these ideas anyway it's it's
very it's very good to see right because
it's much more common to see that a
similar opening comes with similar plans
that the exact move order is super
unique and I think foosley definitely
had an easy win because of that well
Nate is this trying to survive here he's
about to get checkmated so f6 is
checkmate we'll see if voyboy sees I
think he will see it
actually it's very close to Stalin mate
though I guess you capture the pawn I
just realize it's not quite style mate
but it's very very close all right so
maybe boy boys a little bit nervous yeah
I mean it's not quite selling me because
there's a bishop on h6 but wait winner
draws or is connected oh oh well no cuz
I see him in here declining draws okay
yeah okay yeah yeah so he sees the f6
checkmate okay all right yeah so I mean
very tough game for for Nate but I was
very happy with what I saw in that
opening considering how new he is and
I'm sure I'm just gonna replay it as you
say that yeah so as you mentioned you
were happy because he was developing his
pieces properly and I mean he was going
for you know the same structure he plays
against 'if I've and I think it went
very well until we started getting into
the tactical complications when the
bishop was attacked if he would have
grabbed the night I think he would have
had you if you would have grabbed the
night especially before he moved a four
I think he had pretty pretty good
chances to survive even longer yeah I
think that's that's one of important
things also pushing this pawn on the h3
I think it's a very tough concept to
explain but if he had done that he
probably it would have been a more
interesting game perhaps for another
five to ten moves but nonetheless I
think it was it was a great start for
Nate and really no nerves like you I
think you kind of wonder or the players
gonna have nerves only plays obviously
being new to chassis it's like you know
I think a lot of people are
uncomfortable they're not sure what
they're what they're gonna do but the
fact that he had that he just played
some more moves I thought was what was
great and I think it's a great star form
even though he lost the game to get to
to go toe-to-toe for at least the first
10 moves with one of the absolute
favorites overall and voyboy is just
it's it's it's what you want to see yeah
and we are gonna be bringing on voyboy
for an interview soon but before we do
do you have any advice for what you
would tell voyboy so that he can see
ideas like 95 in the future I mean I
actually my take on is I think boy was
actually a little bit nervous cuz again
he's one of the favorites obviously but
you never really know when you're
playing these players who are they
really that knew
as it just as they haven't played in
many many years it played his kids so I
think he was just being a little bit
over cautious in general I'm sure he saw
the move I think it's just he wasn't a
hundred sure and it's just like I don't
want to really take risks I don't know
how good neat is like you know he could
be a total beginner but he could also
not be a beginner he could have played
you know like ten years ago and just
needs to remember certain things so I
think that that boy was just being very
very cautious in trying to take a very
professional attitude yeah that makes
sense
I'll move through the games a little bit
more so Bishop e5 it wasn't a terrible
move if he had the plan of taking the
night but after Queen b6 and a4 was
played I mean the entire next sequence
kind of showed that the follow up idea
wasn't to capture the knight and again I
think this is because he remembered his
chess principles of trying to keep the
bishop pairs so it's always hard to
learn these principles and then no one
to break them right exactly yeah and I
think I think especially when you're
beginning the game it's important to
know that you can trade bishops for
Knights like I I think the whole
material value should generally be going
on the assumption everything is even but
nonetheless if I was not a terrible move
them unfortunately hangs upon but if it
weren't for that that capture it would
have been a completely reasonable move
so I think I think it's it's it's just
really good to see the way that the
people who are knew how they adapt what
they're learning and what sort of
strategies they're using because you're
obviously see some moves that are not
normal but but I thought I thought it
was good I thought it was good overall
and just a few minor things that he
needs to work on but just following the
basics is definitely a good start right
and maybe just one more tip as we go
through the game review after he did
lose the rook Queen takes me to was
offered in general it would have been
you know he would have still lost but if
he was playing against someone his level
maybe you would have had some chances if
he kept his Queens on the board instead
of trading them off here because after
the Queens were traded off we saw boy
boy just go for the simplification so
when you have a piece up one way to go
for when in a more easy fashion is just
to try to trade off as many pieces as
possible
we saw him going for the rook trade then
he started creating weaknesses and mates
attacking the weaknesses in eighths camp
like the
pawn on d3 and then on top of that he
didn't give Nate any counterplay chances
every time Nate had a threat he just
protected it so I think he finished off
the game very cleanly right I would
agree with that as well I thought it was
very clean performance from voyboy
overall perhaps against some of the
other top competitors he might have had
to be a little bit more precise but
overall it was very good and and I think
for him it's very important probably he
got to a good start clean win without
any real drama or nerves or any of that
stuff so certainly the start Savoy was
hoping for absolutely and to just replay
the ending one more time so voyboy did
promote to a queen like we said he's
trying to make it as easy as possible to
win and I like that Nate didn't resign
you know he even offered a couple
cellmates in there for a good laugh and
he tried to put his King in a position
where it has no other square so you know
maybe if there wasn't a bishop on e6 he
would have had some stalemate
opportunity stalemate being when the
game ends in a draw because your king or
any piece cannot move except for the
King isn't attacked on the square it's
currently on right exactly and so I mean
I thought I thought yeah I was a boy
boys a little bit too good to make a
stalemate perhaps but certainly trying
to get the King on one of those squares
were it could accidentally happen it's
definitely what you want to do when
you're way behind
absolutely well on that note you guys
were going to take a short break while
we bring voyboy on for an interview so
stick around and we'll chat with him
soon
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back everyone we're joined by
voyboy who just got his first victory in
pogchamp he just took down nate hill um
congratulations thank you so much yeah
it was a yes I was playing really well I
was impressed and then I got a little
advantage in mid game and I was able to
snowball with it
but yeah I thought I thought I was a
pretty good game yeah I mean was he
stronger than you expected based on his
you know original rating oh yeah
definitely I was really impressed with
the opening and stuff because it was
funny I played a game very similar to
that like an hour before while I was
practicing and then I was like wait this
game looks so familiar but ya know I
thought he was I thought you played well
yeah and he car was actually curious he
card do you want to ask him about the
move you thought he would play after
Bishop III well I thought in this
position you after Bishop III you could
have played this move Knight to e5 um
let me see
okay so it's quite widened plate here or
also even after you castled your King on
the next move I was a little bit
surprised as to why you didn't play it
hmm yeah that that would have been that
have been pretty good I think I might
have missed it I may be considered it at
some point when I was considering other
moves but I don't think I don't think I
crossed my mind is like the primary
plate that I want to make but yeah I see
I see how that I see that how that would
be really good because it tacks the
bishop and then if I the knight can move
and if I take that night pawn takes then
that king is like really bad right so
that's really exactly with a double pawn
so I was just kind of curious if you
slaughter you didn't see it yeah I'm
assuming also for you you're one of the
you're one of the favorites in the event
I was kind of curious if like in this
first game or this first like a couple
of games if you're just trying to be
very cautious because you don't really
know like most these players are new to
chests it also could be something where
they just haven't played for quite a few
years since they were since they were
children um so I was wondering if your
approach is like a little bit different
or a little bit nervous when when like
neat did not blunder in the first like 5
to 10 moves yeah I was like wait this
guy he's just he's playing perfect
chance like what do I like
what am i what am I in for it like no I
mean I I definitely was like pretty
nervous uh like probably here I was I
felt pretty good about the night pin in
the Queen like I felt like his creme is
pretty useless so that that gave me some
like good confidence but yeah I mean
like for example I played a lot just as
a kid I know a lot of other people
playing maybe played quite a bit as a
kid or whatever and just you know never
you know we didn't become world
world-class players like you guys but we
definitely like loved and enjoyed the
game for a while so yeah I'm not I'm not
quite sure how like quite good everyone
is I guess until I play them but I'm
looking forward to you know just seeing
how seeing how the rest that tournament
goes and yeah I thought it was free
pretty strong so I guess were you a
little bit relieved when you saw that
you were able to win a piece I'm
bringing up the position on the board
here after you got his Bishop oh yeah
definitely
I had like hype anime music in the
background and it was such like a stick
like a stale like stable game so I was
like oh god like I had to do something
high feed to like match this music and
then when he did that and I realized I
could get an advantage I felt pretty
good about like the rest of the game of
course and I saw that the rest of your
plan was just to try to trade off pieces
and simplify was this something you were
doing intentionally oh yeah that
definitely I I I think generally as a
concept like once I get a lead I kind of
know like you know it's it's better but
I just had I just had it lesson at the
IMG right and he was talking about how
like
at the beginning of the game for example
one part advantage is in the context of
like the whole board every piece on the
board it's not that important but like
the less piece on the board when there's
only like you know a king and like three
pawns on each side like a one-point man
if you take it as a percentage well I
said this but if you take as a
percentage of like the total strength I
like the board then it becomes like much
more significant so like obviously here
I was up a piece so then you just looked
at trade but even if you're just up like
a little bit I'm trying to think more
about like okay is this like is this
like the time when I'm good with like my
lead and I just want to trade off stuff
and yeah I just try like think more
about you know why why I'm like playing
stuff and like what my strategy is in
the game and it's been it's been pretty
good the last like few days I started
like training more for sure I can see
why you got 2,300 on your SATs but you
just gave such a beautiful explanation
to a well-known chess principle honestly
better than even I could have had so
that was super impressive
ah shucks thank you thank you and
another question I saw that Nate offered
some drawers and yeah he did it once I
was like oh sure he's trying to give me
like to miss click on it and I said no
and I said I was like I hope he just
keeps offering it John like the rest of
the yay like I would honestly even like
like happy with that that's pretty good
but is it good is a good is a good
strategy for sure I respect it sounds
good well um I guess moving a little bit
away from the chess and we know that you
are doing a ton of streaming your full
time story do you want to share a little
bit with our audience oh you got cut off
on a last part I don't know if it's my
internet because my stream died at the
end or my whole internet died at the end
of that game so sorry
yeah so um I know you are you know one
of the top-ranked League of Legends
players do you want to talk a little bit
more of a stream with our audience yeah
I mean I have been I started playing
League in like high school when I was
like you know in the middle of like
I be program and then I just fell in
love with the game I started playing a
lot I started like competing and I just
to start streaming like 2011 and like
going to tournaments and stuff and then
I was competing in the LCS and in 2014 I
retired to full time stream and so
that's what I've been doing for like the
last 6 years and I really love it and
yeah I usually stream League but you
know I've really been loving getting
better at chess and playing it again and
trying to improve and it's been really
cool to see like the whole chess
community grow and like you guys and
just like how much love and hype tres
has been getting cuz like as a kid it
was like one of my favorite things to do
my dad taught me how to play chess and I
loved it like used to play all the time
and so yeah it's just it's just really
like it's kind of surreal to see how how
much hype and love chess has been
getting lately and yes
really feels good man but yeah I'm
definitely still gonna be playing hello
League
I played random stuff all the time and
I'm definitely trying to improve at
chess I was I was trying to calculate
how long it would take me to become a
grandmaster level and and and my boys
era told me if I play for the next 10
years and I put like 2 hours a day in
every day then I might have a chance I
don't know does that sound right Hikari
along those lines
yeah probably more like 4 to 5 hours
every single day but yeah it would be
something insane like that for sure
alright I'll catch you guys on the
chessboard till next day right next ten
years man let's go let's do it
oh and well avoid boy it's really been a
pleasure to have you here a huge shout
out you guys if you haven't checked out
a storage twitch.tv slash boy boy you
are you know a big tournament favorite
so you're gonna have a lot of eyes on
you but congratulations for this first
win and thank you so much for joining us
hey thanks so much for having me it's a
pleasure and I'm really looking forward
to the future games and also check out
my point my opponent knee hill guys he
didn't he didn't get to do the interview
but still a still a cool guy as well
yeah thank you so much likewise alright
you guys let's go to today's pairings as
he mentioned Nate Hill he is a pro
fortnight player if you guys haven't
checked him out yet his stream is super
positive they have so much love there
it's a super cozy community can I say
super anymore yeah you guys should go
super
him there we go moving on so we are
going to have hutch versus moist
critical and I believe we are going to
have GM Hess coming sorry you're
supposed to be shocked at the new xico
sorry sorry sorry yeah I actually saw
that on my other monitor sorry oh and
it's okay key card to genuine to give
the shock there he's always thinking
ahead but we will be back soon you guys
are gonna take a quick break here
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and we're back you guys we saw you
spamming you can't have chest without
Hess so guess who we're joined here
today well I didn't really have a choice
when the chat beckons Here I am and you
guys have been an excellent job oh thank
you so much Robert and I know you've
been doing quite a bit of coaching work
as well can you tell us more about it
sure
with Albert in particular box box we've
had several very long sessions that have
somehow spun off into philosophical
rants and just thoughts about life you
know happiness things like that but I've
been very impressed with his play as
improvement I've talked to boy boy and
we're gonna set up a lesson and he's
just played a nice game there so just
tune into streams keeping the players
company as they continue learning and
growing it's good to see you coaching
the favorites here mmm you're setting
yourself up for some coaching success
Robert I also was just in foolish at
talking to her after her wonderful win
but you know she has a car ooh right so
like the other people you know it's
giving somebody a chance to me hurt
their own stock by giving my coaching
but just have a unique style then they
will not be able to contend with
necessarily a garb come on man yeah well
I mean I was pointed out a couple
different spots I heard that fool
apparently beatbox boxing in a game
after after she played played ear obso I
felt some kind of like weird like
rivalry or something coming down the
road they both somehow make it through
to the next the Champions bracket so it
might be me against you just as coaches
instead of players what can I ask you
like is it kind of hard for you to be
coaching multiple players you're going
to face each other because it is a bit
of a strange dynamic yeah I mean I think
one of the good things certainly as you
can attest to being a grandmaster as
well is that one of the things is we can
play so many different openings I make
it I'm sort of making a mission to try
and show them different openings for
example we could obviously show them the
Italian opening or the for the Rui Lopes
every single game but I think when you
do that there's going to be a very weird
kind of crossover we're showing one
person something and then showing
another person something that's the same
maybe a touch different so I just
generally try to show the players some
strategies that are different from what
their opponents will do so there never
is any sort of like crossover in that
way for sure
Alexandra I've seen zero boats his
gambits today so well you've seen zero
boaters gambits on pogchamp so far but I
have seen some boats as gambits during
the end of my lessons I'm gonna not take
responsibility for it though I think it
happens to everyone
but speaking of coaching do you guys
have any insight into who you think has
been making the most improvement so far
although Robert answer that first well
it's tough to say I actually think some
of the players who really didn't know
much at all about chess and they started
I mean Nate Hill for instance I know he
just lost that game but he's really made
some serious progress foosley
I saw you know her start out just the
way she thinks about the game she
understands like kind of where her
pieces belong and it's not going to be
perfect every single time but just in
that game against Europe I know it ended
so quickly but she was putting her
pieces on good squares she was operating
learning from the strategies that a car
would taught her so she's been
impressive and of course I mean box box
his ascent has been noticed by everybody
and I think he's putting voyboy on alert
and what about you Hikaru what are you
yeah I would tend to agree I think
certainly the improvement as for the
beginners people are very new to the
game it's gonna be it's gonna be more
impressive but I tend to group Robert I
think box box certainly is the person
who's put in the most time I think he
did like a 28 hour stream where he
literally did nothing but play chess so
just in general he's probably putting
the most where he's also improved from I
think when I played him the first time
on stream won't the Queen odd who's
maybe 900 I think now he's pushing 1400
and he's already he's already been able
to be one of us without any odd very
careful that we we don't that we don't
have blue Singh Tim as well honestly
because the fact that he can even play
at that level even even if you even if
you allowed this tactic is it shows that
he is very that he's very talented and
he can convert when he gets gets a big
advantage even even against even against
some of us yes I'm not trying to roast
you I'm just just no I I'm kidding it I
was coaching him he Carl obviously I
wanted to give him confidence you know
what I mean that quiet not too sorry
no I'm kidding that was perfect so you
know we have a lot of new streamers who
are starting to play chess on Twitch and
obviously we've all been really grateful
for the love that the community has got
Hikaru at first and then Robert next
woody you guys kind of think is the
future long term for chess on Twitch
yeah so I mean I think first off there
certainly has been this big boom
recently an in large part due to the
collaborations I did with actually
seeing the fact that it seems like every
big streamer has kind of kind of played
chess as I mentioned on my stream the
fact that someone like Tyler won even it
was only like one or two gets the fact
that something like that play chess
shows that it's become becoming huge
thing on Twitch I think in the near
future going forward it will continue to
be a big category I think there's gonna
there there certainly will be as the
interest might wane at certain points
but I think chess is here to stay and
when you have competitions like this or
you have competitive chess terms which
are being covered as well by like
yourself and Robert I think chess is in
great shape going forward as an eSport
for sure and what about you Robert yeah
I have to agree with that and it's in
large part thanks to all these streamers
to YouTube in particular who've been
growing it from the chest angle and
letting it branch out to others but I
also think that because chess can be a
digestible game where even if you aren't
anticipating every single move you
understand why something is being played
and with the help of explanation that is
something you take away with you and
learning is a lot of fun and people gain
a tremendous amount of insight and value
from it so I think even if you don't
understand what Hikaru and Magus Carlson
are going to be doing seven moves from
now if somebody's explaining here is why
that move just happened here is what I
anticipate the next move is going to be
and this is exactly why people learn a
little bit of something every single
time and those nuggets of knowledge end
up being taken and run away with right
and that reminds me of the commentary
that we've been trying to do for
Hikaru's tournaments while he was
playing Glyn doors for example right and
we saw tremendous audience there where
we have now like 40-something thousand
it was all over fifty thousand earlier I
think people are excited about chess and
I don't see any reason why it has that
excitement has to dwindle
absolutely well on that note thank you
so much for coming Robert I hear that we
are going to soon do an interview with
Nate hill as
and we'll we'll see you for four more
commentary soon chat we'll take a quick
break to bring on Nate and we'll be
right back
[Music]
we are back and joined by Nate Hill Pro
fortnight player on faze clan
he just had to face the strongest player
by rating in the tournament and he put
up a good fight how are you feeling Nate
a good fight that's very generous of you
to say thank you so much I'm feeling
fine I I expected to lose that match
I've seen boy boy and I know he's pretty
good and he's played just for a long
time and I can't expected to lose
earlier than that so I'm feeling ok yeah
that's something he car was saying as
well to go up against someone so strong
even before the game we said we would
consider it a success if you're able to
get out of the opening and try to
survive longer and you're able to do
that so huge congrats thank you very
much yeah it felt kind of it felt close
for a really long time and I think that
was the longest time I haven't it took
for me to lose a piece but eventually
you know crumbled at some point it was a
tough opening do you feel like if you
were playing an opponent more similar to
your level this game based on the
opening would have went differently yeah
I think it was pretty decent I've
actually never seen anybody played the
way he did I don't know what it's called
what he did but I don't think I played
against it it's so one thing that we
were discussing is since Alexandre Koshu
I actually asked her at the start when I
when I asked what you need to play which
was efore and and I told her that boy
would play c5 she sort of it had this
horror on her face she hadn't shown you
any side of you played the opening well
I taught you principles and you did it
was because of the opening your opening
with solid I'm just gonna say that I
remember the core things that you said I
cycle it yes I just gonna say I think we
were both very impressive for someone
who's very new to the game and having
never really seen this opening setup
that you did survive for quite a while
and against the top-ranked player and
the event you were sort of going
toe-to-toe with him for the first about
10 to 11 moves so it was very impressive
to see yeah and actually I'm bringing up
the board if you can see it in the zoom
golf zoom called after Queen b6 so here
if you would have captured his knight on
c6 you
she had a pretty decent position I was
wondering if the reason why you didn't
take that was because you didn't want to
give up the bishop pair yeah I was that
and I just didn't feel like I should
have went a little harder I guess there
earlier I just thought I could defend it
with the pawn but for some reason that
didn't work I guess
trading would have been definitely
better there yeah if you would have been
able to defend your bishop with a pawn
and not be threatened out that would
have been certainly really helpful and
there was another move I'm actually
gonna go back a little bit further that
Hikaru mentioned that was really you
know hard to see for new players here
after he pinned your knight to your
queen did you consider at all h3 to try
to kick his Bishop away you know it's
funny I said that probably like 20 moves
from now I was like I think I should
have done that a lot earlier and now
you're saying it here it kind of
validates that well it's it's certainly
gonna be confirmed for the future there
and then at the end we saw you offering
a draw can you tell us more about that's
enough I just I thought it would maybe
get in his head and I knew I had lost at
some point I tried to bring my King out
to the middle and hoping his would meet
me for like an epic 1b1 final but he
didn't do it so much more interesting
that way that's what I'm saying well he
card do you have any tips you'd give
Nate from this game I thought in general
you played very well you followed the
basics you developed your pieces you
moved your King out a center of the
board I think maybe the only only issue
you had was was not bringing your rooks
into the game you've kind of a little
bit slow with that so perhaps trying to
open up the central part of the board a
little bit more would have been good but
overall I thought we did was fantastic
throughout even towards the end when you
only had the night in the bishop you
actually moved your knight back where
it's a couple times to try and put it on
a better square and most the other
streamers who I've coached they
generally have issues seeing these
backward moves with Knights or bishops
so I thought overall it was a very good
performance leader unfortunately you're
playing it stopped cleared so I was I
was very impressed by your play thank
you very much I think I think I'll get
better as the as the games go on so yeah
and I think in the next games where you
play
who are more similar to your rating it's
going to feel like a very different game
for you right well moving a little bit
away from the chess conversation I know
I already mentioned that you're pro
fortnight's streamer and you have a
really positive chess there anything
else you can share more about how you
got into streaming in the first place
so I basically got into streaming just
because I wanted to play games
professionally and it was very hard to
get noticed
I thought without showing myself and my
gameplay to the world and luckily like
nine months after not streaming for a
bunch of people just grind in every
single day finally started to get
noticed started to win some tournaments
and people started to find me and from
there it's been it's been really great
it's training for like two and a half
years now almost every day and it's been
incredibly fun well it must be pretty
difficult to you know stream and grind
the same game over and over again are
there any other games you stream as well
or mostly focused on for tonight I
pretty much only play fortnight on
stream I'll play a little bit like
hearthstone which card game really fun
dota
katar hero but mainly for night just cuz
the competitive schedule is so it's just
always going on it's never-ending so we
got to stay on top of the game and
that's why people know me for and love
to watch so make sense I mean he card I
have played some for an ID card was
better than I am but I also really enjoy
the game can you tell us a little bit
about what it's like to live the life of
a professional fortnight player it's not
there's not too much to it it's just I
think you guys know how how much time
you put in the chest it's it's similar
to that
like we don't leave our house too much
I'm kind of just hanging out here with
the Chad and the viewers and just
practicing and grinding every day and
yeah it's about it's about it's not that
interesting is it oh pro gamer
I guess it's interesting to watch on the
outside but then when you're actually
the pro player you see all the hours of
grind you're putting it and he'd already
can speak more on this as well yeah I
was gonna say I think it's very similar
chess the only difference being that
just most time it's an over the over the
board game so you played in person as
opposed to online but it's the same sort
of thing like when you're doing scrims
you know with your teammates in chess
it's the same kind of thing where you're
not doing scrims but you're always
practicing and studying opening
strategies whether it's with people that
you know or with computers so the
lifestyles is quite similar for the most
part psyche and it makes a lot of sense
well Nate thank you so much for joining
us chat if you guys want to watch some
awesome fortnight and a ton of
positivity go to twitch.tv slash Nate
Hill you got his username thank you so
much for joining us Nate and being a
good sport you know regardless of the
result thanks Alex thanks Acharya
see you guys soon see you soon all right
well back to today's pairings you guys
we have one more matchup it's going to
be hutch versus moist critical hikaru
what are your predictions for that match
yeah I think this match is a match where
it's the assumptions that hutch is a
much stronger player than moist critical
on based on what I've seen I know that
moist critical has certainly gotten more
coaching hutch hutch is a little bit
rusty I wash and play a little bit on
string yesterday when he actually did do
a bow test yeah but he hung a queen very
well-known clip that I think a lot of
people have seen but I think hutch
should be the favorite but moist
critical is not completely new to chess
so I think there is some potential for
an interesting game III would assume
that hutch is the favorite but I would
not be surprised that this is if this is
a bit of a fiesta fair enough we'll chat
we'll be back soon with this last game
for today thanks so much for all 40 1000
of you guys who are watching
we are about to witness Hutch who is a
top Call of Duty player as well as one
of the few political streamers on twitch
his chest calm rating is about 1,300
take on critical who is a huge YouTube
where he has about 5 million subscribers
and he follows a ton of current trends
his chest calm rating is around 665 they
are gonna face off in the last game of
today moist critical is going to have
the white pieces
we'll see how he's able to handle such a
higher rated opponent Hikaru I asked you
this before would you give him the same
advice you would have given Nate Hill um
no I actually think critical critical is
certainly a little bit more experienced
with chess I think he should definitely
be confident obviously is a big underdog
but I do think he has some chances based
on what I've seen he has certain certain
moments of brilliance or I just saw
someone rights and funny and shots
normal laughing but but but basically I
think he needs to be confident and if he
if he's confident maybe he can pull off
a surprise certainly hutches much more
experienced he's played a lot of chest
but I do think there is a chance for an
upset here I thought I was joking try
not to laugh the same meme shadow yeah
yeah it was hold it in hold it hold it
anywhere but but yes anyway I think
Charlie has a chance but I think he
needs to be very confident and believing
himself the one thing I will say is I
think both players are also gonna be a
little bit slower this game I think
they're gonna think quite a bit more so
this should be this should be a good
match for the game is underway right yep
I'm following it so we got hutch with
the black pieces moist critical with the
white pieces and he's taken some time
here before his first move what are your
thoughts on that oh he didn't realize
the game is started okay hopefully
that's the case I didn't know he didn't
based on his reaction he clearly didn't
realize okay so does he realize oh the
game's probably gonna be a board they'll
just restart yeah yeah he just doesn't
realize I don't think yeah I don't think
he has a tab open I don't think he's
trying to give hutch any time advantages
here so I think I guess since in another
15 seconds the game might be aborted
yeah I think the game should the game
should be a board I think and then
and then they just restart right yeah I
think clearly Charlie she's unaware so
yeah yeah it looks like he's he's fixing
his webcam
okay get chat don't worry we will be
back with with their game very soon and
do you know how long hutch has been
playing chess for I don't know how long
he's been playing but I know that hutch
certainly has done events in the past I
think he didn't have that where he
played against John Herschel in 2017 I
think they played quite a long match so
he clearly has played on played a fair
amount of chess but I don't think isn't
playing that much just recently I think
he's been playing much more call of duty
over the last year or so but certainly
it he is one of the favorites so it's
gonna be interesting to see how he does
considering that the other favorites
what we've only seen boy boy but boy boy
being one of the other favorites had a
very smooth first game so it'll be
interesting to see how the other
favorites in the event start off
absolutely and while we wait for him to
set up we do have the schedule as well
since we are about to see the last game
today tomorrow June 6th
matches are going to be starting at 12
p.m. Pacific and we'll pull up a
schedule so that you guys can see the
players who are going to be live
tomorrow also Himba means I'm a moist
critical is still getting set up here we
go we have the schedule so tomorrow is
the sixth we're gonna have it's slicker
versus NIM and yeah so versus xqc so
that's gonna be a ton of fun and we have
takeoff alright let's get back to the
game so we have e4 e5 Knight f3 knight
c6 okay Knight c3 played by moist
critical okay so far symmetrical they're
mirroring each other same first four
moves
okay so d3 is definitely moved that I
think will surprise hutch okay Hodge
plays Bishop c5 okay this is already
hutch looks very very serious he looks
like he's in it he looks very serious
he's just got that demeanor but seems a
little bit different than the other
players we've seen so far but Charlie
does go Bishop g5 important moves he
doesn't end up in a much worse position
at the very start of the game so he
should probably move his knight up if he
has if he has the opportunity to d5 or
who moved the Queen and develop this
King out of center part ward alright he
plays Knight b5 instead and the computer
doesn't not like this move for him right
because now black can retreat with the
bishop
and let's let's see now a big question
for Charlie here is he's needs to finish
his development so he wants to get the
King out of the middle of the board so
should he move the bishop and get the
king ok please see for I think he's a
little bit lucky than in this position
it's not that bad a move although I
think his idea might be to place c5 next
move uh well we try one of the bishop
that because then he's gonna lose a pawn
here but you're right it seems like he's
going for the pawn pushes before he
develops his minor pieces which i think
is a bad sign in sense of him following
opening principles in general yes but I
think the fact that that a six was
played here and that Charlie it's odd
for me to move the knight back and then
again continue to continue to plan and
move the bishop and get the King out of
the center and get Castle
I think hutch has let him off the hook a
little bit at the start although black
should still be a little bit better
right and do you think hutch is maybe
making his move so quickly like this
because he because of his rating
advantage and he just thinks he's gonna
win regardless um I think it's just that
he sees natural moves and he's trying
not to get too low on the clock I think
also everybody is probably a little bit
nervous cuz I've seen many of the
streamers when they when they've been
playing they've been having trouble with
the clock they've been getting really
low on time and then they just panic and
they make blunders so I think the fact
that everyone's a little bit nervous and
many of them tend to think longer
they're just they're they're moving a
little bit quicker in this in this this
first set of games right well now I
guess we'll see the moment of truth if
we see either I was gonna say 95 or
Bishop e2 to try to castle his king I
like this idea as well although I'm
always nervous when new players don't
castle their King soon enough because
sometimes it might end up in the center
and they'll have to deal with a vicious
attack right so this is a very sort of a
gamble he plays ninety five hundred it
seems to be a little bit nervous he
could have moved the bishop and made it
Chuck which would have been a better
move but he's being a little bit passive
and I think Charlie is in good shape
here if he just moves the bishop and
tries to castle his king but he has to
finish his development right away
because otherwise his King is gonna get
stuck in the middle of the board so he
plays Bishop to e2 Bishop to e2 would be
a good move here and then he castles the
King out of the middle of the board then
he can try to play in the Sun center
part but it's
very critical here I mean pun unintended
it's very critical that he that he does
finish his development right so now
we'll see if he goes for there should be
to what plan do you expect hutch to try
to go for here um I I think hutch will
probably try to push push on the Kings
side maybe push his pawn with the rook
behind it try to open up that file for
his rook or just push the pawn next to
the Queen and finish the development and
and I think that in general this is
gonna be a game that will be slow I
don't think either player is gonna get a
big advantage right away and I think
this is the first time the clock may
play a big role in terms of the outcome
of a game uh-oh so d4 played this is
going to open up White's position here
and he hasn't had the chance to castle
yet maybe he'll play Bishop d3 and Oh
hutch mrs. Queen takes pawn yeah that
was I'm just gonna go back to show chat
if you would have played Queen takes d4
he would have checked the King and
attacked the knight twice so he would
have won a piece here unfortunately do
you think he just played too quickly um
it's hard for me to tell just look
looking at hutch I think he is a little
bit nervous because I get the sense he
hasn't played much just in quite a while
so it seems that he's a little bit
nervous and and perhaps that led to the
last move he is moving I feel like he's
moving a little bit too quickly here
because you do gain time with every move
so I'm not sure I'm not sure what to
make this game I actually kind of like
White's position more here than blacks
position due to the fact that black has
these pawns on b7 + b6 these are very
ugly double pawns they're stacked they
aren't really very good and black
Black's development the rook in the
bishop on their original squares and
they have not come into the game so
there's a little bit of a disconnect and
in blacks position in terms of
development of the last couple of pieces
so I do like I do like this position for
white here I am curious to see how white
will reply to Queen take C far the e4
though because if he just trades off
then he will be down upon and white also
has to start developing soon because his
bishop and his rook on each one haven't
yet made any movement right so I think
probably white smooth moves are very
clear probably develops a bishop I move
the
actually I just saw hutch scoot way back
in his chair and I feel like the fact
they scooted way back means he's not
exactly thrilled with the position that
he has oh man just that temporary thing
right right his room is a little bit
dark and he has that pro mic I feel like
he's recording like a classic rock album
or something okay Queen takes e4 played
right so I think the most natural sorry
go ahead
there are a couple moves you can maybe
take this pawn or you can trade the
Queen's but I this is pretty balanced so
far this is very balanced and with the
limited number of pieces only Queens
rooks and bishops on the board it's a
lot less likely that someone is gonna
blunder material I think this also favor
is most critical quite a bit because the
odds of your opponent surprising you
when they're less pieces or less options
to be played on it's sort of it means
you're less likely to make such blunders
right and if you're the lower rated
player you want to get in these
positions that are a little bit more
simple at least you already start
feeling more confident right exactly so
I think it's very important here it's
really critical that he trades the
Queen's because I'm worried that if he
takes his pawn on the darks we're at b6
the black and maybe play move like pawn
to d5 and then Bishop to f5 lining up a
battery towards the white king that's a
pretty complex plan but as you mentioned
this is the kind of plan hutch might see
so good on white for trading off the
Queen's here and he pushes f3 I'd love
to see him develop his Bishop to d3 that
needs to be done at some point it could
have been done with tempo but it's
important as long as he gets it in in
the next you know two moves yeah so I
think certainly hutch I can tell it
hutches is nervous because I think he's
pleased playing notes critical who's
rating is what is it I can't actually
tell he's at the rating I have is about
600 something versus hutch who is 1300
right so so it seems very clear to me
that when you look at this hutch is
hutch is certainly nervous because when
you're playing someone who's six seven
hundred points lower rated than you you
feel that if you just play normal moves
you don't make any big mistakes you
should just win the game and the fact
that this is not clear at all like I
think you can tell that hutch is just a
little bit nervous
right right and I know you that you have
watched Hutch before in the past so you
can also tell a little bit of his
mannerisms yeah I think I think it's
very critical though this is one thing
that a lot of the newer players have
issues with is bringing the last couple
of pieces into the game and it's very
important that you bring all your forces
and so moving this vision I'm bringing
the roof from the from the H file to the
e1 square is very very important and if
you don't do that you end up it's hard
to chew and that was a mistake
I I don't know that was a mouse lip or
not but that was a big mistake hi I move
the bishop up one more square yes I was
trying to watch for some reactions there
yeah boys is always critical he's
looking down yeah he knows what he's
done
oh no and he had the right idea just not
the right move right yeah and I think
actually now now hutch looks he looks a
lot more like you could kind of see that
it's just like yeah I know no it's uh no
no it's now it's all good for him um but
yeah he needed to move the bishop up one
square so you could develop his work
because if he even if you look now the
black Bishop and the black workers still
in their original squares they had not
been moved so so that there was still
there was an advantage for white that
you could bring the force in before
black and bring those wrinkling about
bring that Bishop and rook into the game
so I wrote d6 I really like because he
might be a piece down but at least he's
blocking the pawn from moving to and
anywhere on the D fall and he's keeping
that Bishop locked it on c8 right
exactly so I think it's it's looking
looking of course very grim for noise
critical but still the fact that he can
maybe keep the bishop and the rook
locked in where they can't come into the
game especially the plays move like pawn
to c5 there are still some small small
possibilities that that he might might
be able to survive to somehow so one
strategy I explained before was
Desperados I know of course you know
what it means but for the audience it's
when you're in a worse position so you
try to go for moves that are not
necessarily the most accurate but they
have the highest likelihood that your
opponent will make some kind of mistake
do you see any of that kind of plan for
a white year um not not really I guess
if you could somehow remove the
rook from this e to square you get the
rook off of this efile and you could
bring a rook to e1 and move the rook up
the board maybe there would be some
chances but I think it's pretty hopeless
and you can tell that Charlie just
leaned back and just like with a little
bit of a grimace he's a he knows that he
he missed he missed an opportunity yeah
and and that was tough because you know
it's really hard to train for blunders
like that do you have any tips I think
in general is just try try to see where
you can move the piece where it's not
our attack and in this case it was a
much simpler position because there were
a lot less pieces on the board but I
think it's a combination look at the
square see if there's something that can
capture your piece and and then if there
is look for other squares you can move
like that fish only having two squares I
it was it's one of the situations where
you just needed to use a little bit more
time to find the right idea to look for
the square to finish the development
where you aren't going to be giving up
anything yeah good point and I just
pulled that up on the board to show we
do have hutch playing rookie six so he's
going for that same simplification plan
that voyboy went for when when he's up
material he's just trying to trade off
right so that that's the one thing when
you're when your opponents have a lot
less force and actually I remember this
I think Albert said this I remember I
was watching watching I think was maybe
like five days ago I was watching Albert
and loosely play play a game and I'll
burn said something about like have you
played have you played Hikaru with the
Queen odds and and I think that's right
when I actually played played foolishly
and and what he said is that like don't
worry if you make trades because it
means your opponent has he Carter will
have less pieces to try and attack your
King with and so in such situations
where you have big material advantage
like you're up by a bishop or Bishop
Knight or even like a rook or queen you
are willing to give back give back like
rooks and bishops or even just exchange
them because that means your opponent
will have less of the major pieces to
attack with right so based on that would
your advice for him be to move his rook
back in this position yeah I think move
they're moving the rook back so that's
because now again what happens is now
hutch will be hutch will exchange one of
the rooks so White has one less work on
the board to attack with and this means
with one rout with one low
rook you really can't really attack the
king and make a checkmate you usually
need like a rook combined with a bishop
a queen or a knight you need two pieces
to attack the king effectively right and
Hutch just continues playing accurately
now he plays B takes c4 he gobbled up
another pawn and soon he'll be able to
push b5 get his Bishop out even if he
loses upon and once his Bishop is into
the game and his rook is also activated
he'll convert to a win exactly yeah so I
think I think this is pretty pretty
hopeless but maybe maybe there's a
chance
I guess now now I'm always critical
trying to push the pawns up the board to
gain some space and maybe create some
hope of a checkmate well I like that
he's doing that you know he's not just
sitting here saying GG the game is over
he's trying to go for that expansion and
that's actually something I really love
from watching players at different
levels compete you know obviously we see
a lot more resignations other Grand
Master stage but earlier on people are
still hopeful about their chances even
if it's you know not gonna happen right
but I would say I would say that's a
good thing because there are the
opportunities that your opponent will
not make the checkmate they might
stalemate you by accidentally where they
don't put the king in check and you've
no moves with your king so I think in
general it's reasonable to keep playing
on and and I think I think here he's
only down one Bishop so it's it's always
worthwhile to keep playing I would not
expect people to make resignations
because the the odds of odds of blunders
are pretty pretty high here now that's
true but it's here it's hard to hear you
as a super GM say only down one Bishop
right but again I mean I think that's
the thing is you have to remember these
players are not gonna find the absolute
best moves so there always is the
possibility of mistakes and I think
that's why also when you look at chess
across the board pretty much outside of
outside of like the Grand Master all
even you will see mistakes people will
make God make small blunders or big
blunders and they're almost always as a
chance that you can that you can come
back right and here I mean if such would
make some really big mistakes a g6 King
g8 and somehow moist can get his rook to
e8 then he actually does have some
checkmate threads and let's see if hutch
I don't think hutch will play King g8
but
that would be one example right I think
that would have been a way to to try and
sell self checkmate yourself right but
at this point I don't think it's gonna
happen because Hutch move the King
towards the center and now again you see
what the lone rook you can't really
attack the King here right well
hopefully he doesn't move his rook away
from this threat I guess another idea he
can try is you know just move his rook
around try to go for the h7 pawn Hut
rule then just defend it I guess I don't
know it's really hard to give advice
here I think the only thing you should
do is just keep playing and hope that
there's some mistake maybe even a mouse
lip right exactly I think it's
definitely worthwhile to keep playing I
would not recommend resigning here I
think there's there's always a chance
you could maybe move the rook over and
try to win that pawn on g7 near the king
like something like rook d4 and I moved
over to F slide and then move it down um
so you could see something like that so
definitely he should keep playing right
and what is your general advice for
people who are new to chess in terms of
resigning should they ever resign um I
would say they should not resign I think
you certainly should play on unless
you're playing someone who's like a
grandmaster where the where Grandmaster
will literally never make a major
mistake
I think certainly you should you should
always play on up and - up until maybe
your your opponent's 1,000 or higher
than that you should you should never
resign never resign that's good advice
chat you heard it here first never
resign critical however is getting low
on the clock as well about two minutes
this will be a good training game even
for that situation though because
learning to play quickly with time
pressures another skill as well right so
I think sir this is the one thing that
has surprised me so far maybe it's
because two of the three matches have
not been have not been what I would say
balance but I'm expecting that there
will be matches where both players get
very low on on the clock and they have
to make moves under pressure and I think
that's when having having some sort of
experience with that will will be will
be advantageous as opposed to say not
having played any games where you're
under that sort of pressure right and
you guys if you have been enjoying these
matches thank
again to 44,000 of you we do have the
schedule if you guys want to give the
channel a follow so that you can see all
of the awesome chests , vents that have
been going on
we'd appreciate it and then it would
help bring more viewership to all of the
streamers who are involved and yeah okay
so on that end
I like that he didn't play a rook at
five to get the rook captured but he's
still going for that idea to put
pressure on the pot on g7 right and I
thought that is a good idea I think at
this point is pretty hopeless but the
fact that he's still finding moves that
attack pieces that that's really the
most you can hope for at this point in
the game so I do like what he's doing
of course hutch doesn't fall for it King
f6 he defends it nevertheless it was
worth a shot
yeah this is this is pretty uh pretty
hopeless because what's gonna happen is
is he'll lose that pawn and black and
push the pawn down the court I think you
can see that Charlie at this point he
realizes that it's kind of gone gone
wrong because he is he is smiling a
little bit he's having he seems a little
bit
it's hutch to you as well well I think
hutch was drinking beer at the start as
well so I think he was but certainly
this this it looks like it looks like
hutch is gonna win and and cement his
status as one of the favorites to
potentially win the whole thing because
he's but he's playing very solidly now
after after he got over that hiccup in
the opening stage he's doing he's doing
pretty well and from what you've seen
with hutches plays so far is this more
or less what you expected yeah I think
hutch is very solid I think the danger
could be that because he seemed so solid
his opponents some of the some of the
other people might be very dangerous and
try to surprise him in the opening
opening phase of the game
and he's doesn't react in a very sharp
or very precise manner he could get in
trouble because in this game he just
traded pieces when he could have won
this pawn on e4 early on and and and so
he might have to be a little bit more
precise but again it's the first game
obviously is playing out someone who he
perceives to be significantly lower
rated so you're not gonna be as as sharp
in a way right so then in group a we're
going to have hutch and voyboy who are
kind of leading the pack and then we
also have quite a few players who are
more close
to the 1,000 reg so foosley yob nate
hill and moist critical from the four
who are not you know the rating
favorites who do you think has been
performing the best so far today other
than fools see with her opening prep uh
I think neat Hilde relative to how new
he is the game has performance the fact
that he was able to get to move town or
move eleven without making significant
blunders against voyboy probably would
be the the player who has shown the
shown the best performance considering
how new they are to the game
I feel like moist critical actually was
sort he sort of had a real chance in
this game because because Hutch was not
super aggressive in the opening phase
but unfortunately made the one critical
mistake and the one water he did make
kind of it was just he couldn't he he
that one Blair was just too much right
and Hutch is playing this really well
now I mean he's defended all the threats
he has not only an extra Bishop but the
extra past pawn that he seems to be
going for he knows that his king is
important in the end game and of course
white is doing his best here but it's
just a tough impossible yeah but never
resign right Hikaru yeah yeah it's kind
of all gone wrong but but on the flip
side you can tell that Charlie's having
a good time and I think that's other
things when you see the people even if
they make a blunder the fact they're
still having a good time they're not
like they're not like yeah upset or
something I I think I think it's really
it's really great to see yeah this is
very different from when you watch
professional chess games and whoever
lost looks like it's just been the worst
day of his entire life here we got some
laughter and continuing on regardless
right I think that's a good thing
especially in this stage I think when
you get to like the final stage and the
champions brag like the semi for the
finals people will be very very serious
of course but you want to see people
having fun and having a good time
regardless of how new or how long
they've been playing the game and I
think certainly we've seen that on this
first day right well it does look like
there is a checkmate and about two moves
here let's see if hutch is going to yeah
hutch is gonna spot it yeah here we go
Queen d3 is checkmate Yaya
yeah that's that's to be expected from
hutch he's pretty sound tactically
that's what you've been saying the
entire time and he just proved it with
that pretty quick find actually of the
maiden - yeah I think hutch has a very
good fundamental base of understanding
based on the openings that he's playing
so it seems to me he's probably the
player who's played the most chess in in
this group I mean I think boy boy boy
boy and box box are probably slight
favorites over him but he's one of the
guys who's played probably the most
shots and had the most experience so
it's no surprise that he's so that the
fundamentals of his of his play are so
good absolutely and I'm just gonna run
us back to the opening as well as there
anything you want to comment on that
stood out to you before the blender well
I think I was surprised that the Charlie
did not push the pawn to d4 to open up
the center part of the board one of the
things is when you get these positions
that are very closed it can be very hard
to play them if you don't have an idea
in mind and once he puts the pawn on d3
I was very happy to see that he went
Bishop to g5 here to try and try and
exchange the bishop for the night
because otherwise he could have ended up
in trouble immediately so most of things
he did I thought were fine although he
did violate the opening principles by
not developing his King right away and
he was a little bit lucky to not get
punished but again it's the first game
and and I thought that overall his
performance is pretty good it's just
unfortunately the one mistake he made I
think everybody's gonna make mistakes
and I'm catching up to that board now
right the one mistake that he made
unfortunately it was it was just a
little bit too too severe even though it
was only a bishop there's just too much
to recover from right because if you
would have moved Bishop to d3 I mean
obviously he is still down upon here but
as you mentioned hutch doesn't have his
bishop or his rook defended and it would
have still been enough compensation for
him to try and fight on here right I
think I think at this point if this were
let's say a professional game I think
that white is completely fine because
even though black has its plus one with
an extra pawn the two ponds on the b7
and B six squares they're they're
isolated where they can easily be
attacked pawns don't protect each other
and I think I think would have been very
interesting to see what would have
happened if this should be through is
played unfortunately we won't we'll
never know
Charlie push me to but but I thought I
mean I thought in general Charlie played
well hutch played well was just the one
mistake just it was a little bit
careless and it just cost in the game
well summarized on that note Chuck we
will be taking a short break and we'll
be back soon with player interviews
thanks so much for everybody who's been
tuning in
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and we are back we are joined with we
are joined by hutch who just took down
moist critical in his first game in
Prague jams congratulations hutch thank
you appreciate it it seems like he
played a really good game until that
blunder then was his a performance of
the opening surprising to you at all
a little bit yeah III didn't get to move
my LightSquared bishop or my my h8 rook
for I think 30 moves so that was a
little frustrating yeah that's for sure
I mean he car was joking that you seemed
like a little bit nervous because he was
playing so well I'm having a panic I get
like I'm feel pretty comfortable with
chess but in these kinds of situations I
choke like consistently so I'm glad I
didn't choke well I heard that you had
been playing chess rulers quite some
time can you tell us how you got into
the game yeah I got into chess about it
was I think 2004 so about 15 years 16
years and I found the game when I was at
like a real low point in my life and
focusing on the game and improving in
the game and just getting immersed in
the game and getting lost in it you guys
understand what it's like to be obsessed
with chess just really got me out of
that bad spot so I can credit chess for
like a lot of what it took for me to get
out of that so I just yeah I've been a
huge fan of this game for a long time
I've been trying to get chess to become
like a thing like on twitch and on
YouTube for a little while now and so
it's it's it makes me really happy to
see chess pulling up right now is
particularly with you too
I think you guys are doing something
really cool here so congrats yeah we
really appreciate those words and in
terms of the players that you're gonna
go against in your division obviously
voyboy is gonna be a big rival you got
any strategy to try to take him down um
I'm definitely gonna pull up his Bloods
and watching his games and see what kind
of openings he likes that kind of thing
I think I have time before I play him
though right like I think it's not for
another couple weeks maybe but um
yeah he looks like a pretty strong
player I watched him play Nate yeah he
has been playing very well I know he's
been putting in quite a bit of training
time and I know that you've been
preparing to do some coaching as well
but you know things have been pretty
crazy on your streams you want to tell
the audience a little bit about that do
you want to be what do you mean okay
yeah well let me not throw you some hard
questions here I know that you're a Call
of Duty streamer but you also do
politics on division and obviously right
now has been a time in the US where
politics does the forefront of
everything so you've been tackling some
hard issues on on stream yeah I was
gonna I wanted to get lessons from you
this week and then things really started
popping up in the streets and I wanted
to take the this week to really like be
engaged in that and I went out marched a
couple days ago and so I appreciate you
guys giving me the lessons and offering
me that kind of thing
and I'm sorry I couldn't make time for
that but there's like a huge pivotal
social event going on in the world right
now and so I couldn't miss that right
and if you guys want to hear more of
hutches thoughts on what's going on make
sure to check him out on twitch.tv slash
hutch and on that note to move it a
little bit from something so heavy he
card you have any moments in the game
where you think hutch could have played
something better maybe we can show it to
him and get his thoughts sure so I was
kind of surprised in the opening that
you played so quickly others this one
moment out of the opening where you
could have taken this pawn on e4 I was
kind of curious if you saw this at the
time you show me that on the screen I'm
catching catching you up here okay so
you traded the Knights here and you
could have actually taken the pawn on e4
with your queen instead of trading the
Knights I'm just kind of curious if like
you're the moves you were playing if you
were just like a little bit nervous just
trying to get this first game under the
belt or what you're sort of thought
process was general um yeah I just
played too quickly in the opening I
missed it
I I learned chess with like five minutes
chefs blitz chess and coffee shops and
so I'm just used to making moves like
super fast careless mistakes can you
explain to me why like what what I could
have done to not have my bishop and rook
locked in they're fixed right so I think
the main thing that you could have done
if we go back a couple of moves was
specifically well first of all after 95
I view at a very good move I think
Bishop to a5 Chuck was very strong here
right my guess if before your queen is
still under attack but you can take on
b4 with check okay so so that was the
first thing I thought you could have
done the other thing you could have done
was instead of allowing this 95 instance
you actually didn't need to push the
knight back right away to c3 like you
could have just gone d6 right here
played like d6 and castles and the
knight doesn't really ever attack the
pawn on c7 because your Bishop guards it
so you can sort of finish your
development and wait for the right
moment to kick the knight out of that
square yeah so I think that was the big
big big R beam you had because the game
it actually if if if your opponent had
not put the bishop on each with you gone
Bishop d3 it would have been very tricky
because the bishop and rook were not
coming into the game yeah I had to plan
like five moves ahead to try to just get
them out of that little box I had to
move my king up to support the pond at
one point at the endgame there and then
I was yeah well you actually played the
endgame really well after you got the
extra piece there it was actually still
tricky even though you were up a full
Bishop you had to figure out the plan of
how to get out of the box there so that
was really impressive yeah it's it took
some that was frustrating honestly
because I felt like yeah that was
frustrating it's like that thing with
the thing with chess though is that
it'll get away with you before you even
really understand all it takes is like
to imprecise moves and all of a sudden
you up to minor pieces just stock for 30
moves and that's just the way chess is
but that's one of the reasons why the
game so great right well I mean this was
an awesome game from your and after
you're able to get the bishop and even
though the opening was a little bit
tricky you managed to develop those
pieces and hopefully with he carves tips
in terms of playing a little bit more
slowly in the opening you do have more
time even as a blitz player and the tip
about how you could have less tonight on
b5 well we'll see even a little more
improvement for future games yeah I'm
taking notes well thank you so much for
joining us hutch and once again chat if
you like Call of Duty's or politics
check them out on Twitch and on you
I know you have a really large YouTube
following as well thank you I really
really appreciate you guys taking the
time to give me some lessons here and
putting on this event I think it's great
what you guys are doing thank you so
much hutch for helping popularize chess
we'll now go to the pairing and we'll
see you soon okay thank you guys all
right Chet so these are the games we saw
today we saw foosley take down a Rob we
saw voyboy
take down eight hill and we just saw
hutch take down moist critical
hikaru basically kind of predicted these
results anything you'd like to add um no
I mean I thought it was very is very
there's a lot of fun the first game
especially being probably the closest
match of the three matches I think boy
was a big favorite hutch was as well but
I think certainly with the first game
with when players are evenly matched you
see it you see a lot of interesting
games and I think we're gonna see more
more pairings which are which are gonna
be more more evenly balanced and we're
gonna get some some great play and
they're definitely going to be some
games where both players don't have a
lot of time there's gonna be real
pressure so I'm just looking forward to
seeing seeing the next set of set of
games and tomorrow especially I'm really
excited for the game between xqc and
Yasuo I think that is a game that has a
lot of potential to be full of blunders
and full of drama so I'm really looking
forward to that one especially on day
two well until then we have one more
interview chat we're gonna go to a quick
break to set it up and we'll be back
with moist critical
well we are joined here by moist
critical I officially now have the third
best hair on screen but that's all right
what is critical thanks so much for the
fantastic performance you did today all
the way until that Bishop blender can
you get us in your head a little bit
what happened there well you see I had
one one plan in mind all day I wanted to
play high octane fundamentals and then
all at once I took a [ __ ] I have no real
excuse for what happened with that
Bishop I'm sure my coach Daniel GM turbo
GM eternal GM Daniel will definitely
have some words on that play for me but
I just crumbled under the pressure and
I'm trying to load the game I'll get it
started soon but did you consider moving
your bishop instead to one square over 2
d 3 on that move yep that's what I
wanted to do initially and then I just
started to I don't know I guess rush I
think I still had like 5 minutes 30
seconds or something around that point
and I think I was just trying to push a
little too fast and didn't didn't
analyze properly
fair enough and he card you have any
comments on the speed of which he played
his opening I actually thought you
played very well I certainly hadn't
prepared for this opening setup but I
liked what you did I'm getting rid of
your bishop early for the night and then
putting your knight in the center of the
board um I thought pretty much most of
the game he played very logical very
straightforward moves and until you hung
this bishop so I thought what you did
today if you do that in upcoming games
certainly will bode well for your
chances so III thought you did you did
pretty well it was it was difficult
you're playing someone who's much higher
rank than you were but you got a good
position and I think you were doing fine
till about move 20 or around there until
you hung the bishop so definitely
definitely very good man
so what does this I hear about you
saying xqc will probably beat me are you
talking some [ __ ] did I say that
someone was saying that I don't think I
actually said that it's trying to meme
you okay I mean I might have said
something like I thought he's a better
chance of making the champions Brack but
I didn't say anything specific about him
being better than you there's no chance
I I'm gonna make this like a WWE
promotional the
no [ __ ] chance I loosed xqc if I'm
see I retire from chess forever by the
way there is a chance you will plan you
do realize there's also a consolation
bracket so there is there is like
probably a one in four chance that
you're gonna play him in the up in the
bracket after these three games good
three stay up every single night all
night practicing chess for the showdown
there and it would be more intimidating
if we aren't about to pull up the
position they shot me too that is a low
blow for no reason what I don't know why
I deserve to be ridiculed like that I
felt pretty confident up until then a
highlight reel perhaps like my phase
montage of good chess moves well yeah
let's start through this I see car was
saying I mean honestly you're opening
really impressed us and there were quite
a few mismatched games today so you're
obviously the lower rated opponent going
against hutch but you are the lower
rated opponent who I think got the best
position against your higher rated
opponent so that's actually a big
accomplishment to be decided by just one
blender shows that your fundamentals are
pretty strong
perfect that's what I set out to do that
was the game plan today well we really
liked that Knight to d5 of as well I
mean you put your knight in the center
right away how did you start learning
with these opening principles so well
well I'd like to say it came to me in a
dream as like a galaxy brain prodigy of
chess but unfortunately I was taught but
taught by one of the best in the
business of course talking about the
omega GM Daniel Nerdist Nara Martin Arad
it's key if that's how you pronounce his
last name I'm sure he'll give me some
[ __ ] if I pronounced it wrong but yeah
he taught me quite a few things a couple
days ago that I've been trying to
implement into my repertoire of deadly
chess moves and can you tell us a little
bit about how you got into chess
originally my grandpa taught me when I
was young we used to play on like a
little fish board or not a fish board a
chess board of pieces that were fish he
thought it'd be fun to teach me how to
play that's kind of cute you probably
knew that
oh yes son one day you'll go up against
the mighty xqc and you've been just
training for this moment whole life 100%
I'll be ready I I fell apart towards the
end today but I'm telling you I'm gonna
be like a stone next time Oh
well he card do you have any tips for
moist critical for what he can try to
improve that would make him improve as
quickly as possible I thought most of
stuff you did was very good the only
thing I would try to remember is
remember that you should develop your
piece and get your king out of the Sun
of the board that was the only thing
like the way you played it worked out
there was probably one move when when
your opponent could have probably caused
you some bold danger but overall I
thought it was good just remember that
you want to be aggressive and attack but
you also need to you also need to move
your bishop and get your team out of the
center of the board before you go on the
fool offense you know before like you
kick the high-octane stuff really indeed
yeah I agree I think I was just way too
slow developing pieces I think I had
that bishop there like that entire game
until I blundered it so the funny thing
is the way you played it you got a very
good position as when you push this pawn
it was actually a mistake but it's the
right idea to free space for your bishop
so it can develop and you were probably
you were probably much better action in
the game until you blundered the bishop
I think because if you just go forward a
couple moves Alexandra yep so this
position after black takes and you take
what you showed done here was move to
Bishop to d3 right away oops
sorry I tried to put on the board and
the board went desert so if you move the
bishop out and then then you are like go
back one more move there yes so if you
go there and then you bring the other
rook into the game you're all your
pieces are developed and blacks broken
as bishop or kind of stuck on their
original squares because the way the
pawn pawns are you can't you can't bring
them into the game quickly yeah it makes
sense yeah I I really should have played
that d3 move that was the first move I
was gonna make but I just didn't feel
too confident in it I thought maybe I
could try and do something like some
kind of attack on his King side over
there if I had placed the bishop more
back but well one thing I was saying
here look if you're looking to attack
the black King the bishop is almost
always gonna be a tower be better on the
diagonal towards that square next to
King on h7 mm-hmm like the bishop almost
always will be better on that long
diagonal so if you're if you if you get
reach positions where you can attack you
want to Bishop on that diagonal instead
of on the e2 square where it has less
less ideas towards the King yeah that
makes sense
and I just drew those on the board well
hopefully those tips are going to be
somewhat helpful we know that you also
have a really big
YouTube channel that you actually
covered some chest drama there before we
let you go do you want to just tell chat
a little bit more about what you do on
YouTube so they can check you out it's
they're interested I do it's it's hard
to find the right words for what I do
it's kind of like just an open diary of
just crazy [ __ ] it's like sometimes
games sometimes movie reviews a lot of
times I'm playing with sex toys and
using them as weapons other times like
music it's just a whole bunch of
different [ __ ] and then I'll cover like
chest drama rants and stuff like that so
it's just a big goodie bag of Internet
content I suppose yep from weaponize sex
toys to chest drama seems like the
natural progression there I think I
think everyone would really be surprised
if you take nothing else away from today
I think the thing to take away is just
how versatile sex toys can truly be like
there's so much more to them than they
get credit for just so many different
purposes that I think a lot of people
don't stop and really think about it and
that's kind of what I try and do educate
people on taking an object like a
flashlight a rubber vagina and seeing it
in a different way it's kind of like on
a chessboard you know there's so many
different possibilities and I think the
same can be said about sex toys look
I'll say something chess players usually
anticipate moves ahead but I did not
anticipate that answer thanks so much
here today you've been a lot of fun and
a lot of surprises
thank you I'm telling you I'm take I'm
gonna take it all I'm gonna win the
tournament mm-hmm
yeah we're we're gonna switch off now
thanks so much for forever he walked and
they watched and thank you for the
interview
see
okay well we have the schedule before we
go off so tomorrow it's going to be June
6 and we're gonna have it's slicker
versus NIM and you're salvers xqc it's
yeah oh by the way what say that again I
think it's yeah so yeah so thanks I need
to work out my pronunciation appreciate
it so yeah so vs. xqc and that is a
matchup that he car was super excited
for hopefully we'll see you guys tuning
in again yeah I hope you guys enjoyed it
and if let me just quickly check the
zoom call if there's anything else we
should show as well we'll go there
otherwise we're just gonna sign off
thanks so much everybody
see you guys
you